Hallo, hier ist Chaosradio Express, Ausgabe Nummer 58. Die letzte Sendung ist noch nicht mal online, weil ich mal wieder was vergeigt habe. Das dauert noch ein bisschen. Mal gucken, ob die Sendung glatt noch vorher rauskommt. Aber ich denke nicht. Wie auch immer. Hallo, willkommen. Mein Name Tim Pritlove, wie immer. Die Moderation bei Chaosradio Express. Und wir haben heute den 4. Dezember 2007, nur noch zwei Tage, bis das Stiefelchen sich öffnet. Und ihr hört schon, ich bin nicht alleine. Wie sollte es auch anders sein bei Chaosradio Express? Constanze ist da. Hallo, Constanze. Was hast du denn im Stiefel dann? Hast du so Verehrer, die so einfach was reinstecken?
Ja, draußen hab ich mir überlegt hinstellen, also nicht auf dem Flur, sondern vor das Haus. Vielleicht packt ja da irgendeiner was rein.
Ehrlich gesagt, hab ich mir wenig Gedanken darüber gemacht. Ich hab so ein etwas lockeres Verhältnis zu religiösen Feiertagen. Ja, das vielleicht auch. Aber das sollte nicht das Thema sein, denn das Thema heute lautet der 24. Chaos Communication Congress, Insidern auch bekannt als 24C3. Der Kongress ist ja, wie von euch wahrscheinlich nahezu alle wissen, unsere jährliche Veranstaltung und die steht nun bald wieder an. Vom 27. bis zum 30. Dezember, wie gehabt, vier Tage im Berliner Kongresscenter am Alexanderplatz in Berlin. Und ja, da erwarten wir euch alle wieder, um euch mal ein bisschen den Mundwässrig zu machen. Und vielleicht auch die Leute, die bisher immer geglaubt haben, es würde sich nicht lohnen, seinen Skiurlaub abzusagen oder die Familie vorzeitig zu Weihnachten zu verlassen. Den wollen wir heute ein bisschen Material, Argumentationsmaterial liefern beziehungsweise einfach mal erzählen, was eigentlich so auf dem Kongress so geht. Vielleicht auch mal ein bisschen generell noch mal für die Leute, die den Kongress nicht kennen, aber dann vor allem wollen wir durch das Programm durchmarschieren und interessante Vorträge, der es dieses Jahr wieder viele gibt, vorstellen und so ein bisschen auch erzählen, wie wir dazu kommen, solche Themen auszuwählen, warum wir gerade jetzt diese Themen auch interessant finden und so weiter. Und wir haben auch ein Motto. Und wir haben auch ein Motto und damit fangen wir vielleicht mal an. Das Motto lautet?
Volldampf voraus.
Volldampf voraus. Was steckt dahinter?
Oh, ich dachte, das erzählst du, weil du doch der Steampunker von uns beiden bist und ein Steambaby zu Hause hast.
Naja, weiß ich nicht. Also die Idee, also das hast du jetzt schon durchklingen lassen, die Idee ist, eine Assoziation zu finden zum Steampunk, einem kulturellen Phänomen, was allerdings in den USA, also im englischsprachigen Raum, generell viel ausgeprägter zu sein scheint, als jetzt hier in Deutschland oder im Festland Europa. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie die Engländer darauf abgehen, aber...
Es gibt auch gar keine Übersetzung, das ist mir dabei immer aufgefallen.
Dampfpunk, naja, es gibt für Punk nichts Dampffreundliches, oder? Also, schwer zu sagen, aber kurz gesagt, viele Deutungen greifen da wahrscheinlich ins Leere, aber ich sehe es immer so. Es ist so ein bisschen der Spaß, unsere moderne Hochtechnologiezeit zu vergleichen mit der Einführung der Dampfmaschine damals, die im Prinzip so der Vorbote des industriellen Zeitalters war. Und die damals doch revolutionären Auswirkungen, die wir gehabt haben durch die Mechanisierung und dann eben auch durch die Dampfmaschine eben, die finden wir ja heute in ähnlicher Form auch in digitalen wieder so. Die Strukturen ändern sich, die Wege ändern sich, die Zusammenhänge von Ort und Zeit ändern sich. Natürlich auch die gesellschaftlichen Strukturen ändern sich mit den wirtschaftlichen Strukturen mit. Und Steampunk ist allerdings, also hat viele Ausprägungen. Es gibt natürlich da die philosophische Ausprägung. Retro-Futurismus, ich hoffe, dass ich das vor dem Kongresse auch noch bei Chaosradio Express noch mal in der einen oder anderen Form unterbringen kann. Mal schauen. Ich hab mir ja zur Regel gemacht, hier keine Versprechungen zu machen. Ich mach dann immer trotzdem welche und die Sachen, die ich immer verspreche, die hauen dann auch mal nicht hin. Das ist total elend. Wie auch immer, ganz offensichtlich gibt es aber da so eine sehr nette Bastelszene weltweit, die sich dann so messigen, beschlagene Laptops und ähnliche Sachen macht. Also alles hat so ein bisschen diesen Dünkel von viktorianischem Zeitalter, und mechanisch irgendwie. Umkleidet aber halt Hightech. Und das ist so das, wovon sich die Organisationscrew dieses Jahr auch hat leiten lassen.
Voll am Voraus.
Ist allerdings auch ein wenig doppeldeutig, obwohl das nicht jeder natürlich so sieht. Es ist ein bisschen mehr auch so die Botschaft von innen, die einfach reflektiert, dass einfach beim Club dieses Jahr so viel gegangen ist, wie schon lange nicht mehr. Die Themen sind euch ja sicherlich alle zu eigen gemacht. Schon mit, wie man sagt, die Liste ist so ewig lang, Online-Durchsuchungen, die ganzen politischen Themen, die auf der Agenda sind, Überwachung, Wahlcomputer und so weiter. Es ist viel passiert und CCC hat an der Stelle auch, wie soll man sagen, Eigenlob stinkt, aber es ist mal wieder etwas bewegt worden. Das war ja gerade vor zwei Jahren auch die Diskussion, die vom Kongress ausging mit dem Vortrag von Frank und Rob, we lost the war, so diese harte These mit Jungs, kommt mal klar, wir feiern uns hier immer selber, wie cool wir doch sind, und was weiß ich, Robin Hood in den Datenwäldern.
Wir müssen verstehen, dass es jetzt vorbei ist und dass wir schon verloren haben.
Genau, aber eigentlich verlieren wir halt eine Schlacht nach der anderen. Das ist eigentlich auch derzeit noch immer nicht so richtig viel anders, mit wenigen Ausnahmen. Mit dem Wahlstift gab es hier zumindest einen Teilerfolg zu feiern, holland auch mit Wahlcomputern generell, auch das ein Thema auf dem nächsten Kongress. Aber die neuen Überwachungsgesetze, die halt allesamt einfach genauso beschlossen wurden, wie sie lange Zeit angedroht wurden, müssen dann halt auch erst mal wieder letztinstanzlich von Verfassungsgericht bekämpft werden, und das ist natürlich ein untragbarer Zustand.
Na ja, vielleicht hat sich aber dennoch ein bisschen was in der Stimmung geändert, einfach weil gerade hier so bei der Demo in Berlin man merken konnte, wir sind irgendwie nicht die Einzigen, die finden, dass da was falsch läuft, sondern dass sie einfach mehr Leute zusammenfinden und verschiedene Gruppen in der Gesellschaft sagen, nee, es misst. Und ja, mittlerweile ja sogar die Grünen auf ihrem Bundesverteidigungsag plötzlich wieder die Bürgerrechte auf ihre Agenda gehoben haben.
Genau, auf einmal jetzt neue Bürgerrechte. Ja, genau. Der Trend geht natürlich schon länger. Im Prinzip hat das 2001 angefangen, dass man schon so gemerkt hat, und das war auch im Club zu spüren, dass auf einmal die jungen Leute wieder ein viel größeres Interesse haben an gesellschaftspolitischen Themen, als das in den zehn Jahren davor war, wo alles so getragen war von dieser Cyberwelle und wir sind jetzt alle coole Hacker und Internet und alles ist irgendwie World Wide Web und nichts ist unmöglich. Es war einfach so eine Abenteuerlust, die einfach auch extrem verspielt war und die einfach mehr so von den Möglichkeiten geleitet war und wo alles auch recht positiv gesehen wurde. Und dann halt einfach diese krasse Zäsur, in der dann wieder die Stimmung geschaffen wurde für neue Überwachungsgesetze, die wir halt beim Club generell einfach ablehnen, weil das ist einfach mal eine scheiß Idee. So und das ist natürlich auch ein Thema auf dem Kongress. Es ist es schon immer gewesen und in diesem Jahr natürlich wieder auch.
Klar, wir haben ja auch immer noch den Rückblick. Also wir haben ja dieses Jahr sogar einen zweistündigen Rückblick, wo wir auch nochmal erzählen werden, was eigentlich in dem Jahr alles passiert ist.
CCC-Jahresrückblick, wo berichtet wird, was passiert ist.
Das ist ja echt viel, die sind ja.
Deswegen auch zwei Stunden sozusagen.
Deswegen auch zwei Stunden. Wir haben ja einige Beschwerden darüber, dass der immer nur einen Stunden Slots gibt und dieser nun zwei Stunden hat. Aber wir hätten einfach auch nicht diese Thema nicht in einer Stunde.
Eigenbedarf nennt man das.
Eigenbedarf, genau. Wir wollen ja auch Leute dazu kriegen, mitzumachen. Diese Veranstaltung dient ja am Ende auch so diesem Gruppenkuscheln und Selbstmotivation.
Recruiting heißt das heutzutage.
Nee, so würde ich es aber nicht nennen. Ist ja ein imperialistischer Kampfbegriff.
Genau, so nennt das nur Google, wir nennen das anders. Wie auch immer. Wir möchten euch natürlich gewinnen für unsere Sache. Gar keine Frage. Das ist keine Neuigkeit, aber ich denke, dass wir da auch alle ein gemeinsames Interesse daran haben. Du warst ja jetzt wieder mit dabei, ganz eifrig bei der Konferenzplanung. Ich diesmal nicht. Ich habe Pause und vielleicht sollten wir mal ein bisschen darüber reden, wie das eigentlich so angegangen wird. Wir hatten vor, was war jetzt, mit dem 21.3., also drei Kongresse zurück, wurde ja überhaupt das erste Mal das ganze Thema Konferenzplanung vollkommen neu angegangen. Also man hat sowas wie einen Call for Papers und so weiter, gab es halt lange Zeit nicht, weil die Organisation des Kongresses auf viel weniger Schultern ruhte. Das hat sich jetzt geändert, es findet sich jetzt immer ein Team zusammen.
Mehr oder eigentlich viele Teams.
Genau, aber es gibt da halt ein Team von wieviel Leuten auch immer, die sich halt um den Inhalt kümmern. Und dann gibt es auch eine ganze Menge Einreichungen. Wie viele Einreichungen gab es dieses Jahr?
Also 200 bestimmt. Also ich muss sagen, dass ich die genaue Zahl jetzt gar nicht weiß, aber es waren schon, also ich würde mal schätzen, vielleicht ein bisschen unter 200, weil das kämpft. Aber im Sommer hatten wir recht knapp.
Der Vorlauf war nämlich kürzer.
Aber es war schon recht viel.
Und wie viel haben es dann jetzt letzten Endes geschafft?
Also der Fahrplan ist noch nicht komplett. Wir haben erst die Version 005, das heißt, wir haben noch einige Lücken, wo wir noch auf Bestätigung warten.
Aber es gibt jetzt einen Track weniger, ne?
Na ja, wir haben jetzt...
Es gibt drei Tracks.
Das ist richtig, aber dafür haben wir jetzt mehr Workshopprogramm. Aber ansonsten haben wir auch die Pausen so gelassen wie letztes Mal, weil wir es kurz angenehm gefunden haben. Also man kann halt mal eine Stunde essen gehen. Wir wollten das nicht so stressig machen wie auf diesen Business-Konferenzen.
Ich denke, das hat gut funktioniert, so gerade mit den 15 Minuten genereller Denkpause nochmal zwischen zwei Veranstaltungen, damit man einfach mal Zeit hat, von einem Raum zum anderen zu gehen. Aber diesen Saal 4 unten gibt es so nicht, sondern das ist jetzt Workshop-Raum, dafür gibt es eine andere Strukturierung, eine größere Lounge. Es ist wieder einmal, wie das ja immer auf dem Kongress ist, organisatorisch ein bisschen weitergedacht worden und wir sind immer wieder gespannt, wie das aufgeht.
Naja, wir kriegen halt auch jede Menge Feedback und wenn man sich mal ansieht, was da so für Vorschläge kommen, dann muss man sich einfach jedes Mal überlegen, was kann man ändern, was kann man verbessern. Und im Prinzip immer wieder neue Ideen, die wir haben und die setzen wir einfach um.
Ja, vielleicht nochmal so zur Arbeit des Konferensteams selber. Es ist immer klar geworden in den letzten Jahren, dass so manche Entscheidungen, die so gefällt wurden, was halt aufgenommen wird, was nicht aufgenommen wird, wird dann halt von Referenten oder Besuchern in der Blogosphäre oder in anderen Orten halt auch öffentlich aufgegriffen.
Oder kritisiert.
Genau, ist natürlich auch schon fast wieder ein Politikum, weil der Kongress halt auch mal so diesen, weißt du, in der Öffentlichkeit natürlich bei vielen Leuten auch so diesen, ah, so ist das jetzt ein Thema, was wert ist, auf den Kongress zu kommen. Oder, oh Gott, ist das abgelehnt worden. So wird es jetzt in der Verdammung verschwinden. Also wie läuft das ab?
Also man muss einfach mal...
Wie ist das abgelaufen?
Vielleicht mal so ein bisschen unterscheiden zwischen der Konferenzleitung und diesem sogenannten Content-Team, also dem Team, was sich nur mit dem Inhalt befasst, also mit den Einreichungen, die kommen. Also nicht, dass man verwechselt. Also weil das sind alle verschiedene Teams, die sich da um die einzelnen Sachen kümmern. Und im Content-Team ist es halt so, dass zunächst mal, bevor man sich das allererste Mal trifft, besteht so aus acht bis zehn Leuten etwa, dass man dann schon mal alle einzelnen Vorträge anguckt. Und wir haben ja, Tim würde das vermutlich kennen, das Band-About-System, was eine große Hilfe ist für die Planung. Da gibt es die Möglichkeit zu reviewn, das heißt, man kann dort mit zugeordneten Werten, aber auch verbal eine Bemerkung reinschreiben und einfach sagen, ja finde ich gut, will ich haben oder bin ich noch unentschlossen oder nee, also interessiert mich überhaupt nicht. Und so entsteht ein Meinungsbild. Und die Leute, die das Review machen, sind sogar deutlich mehr, als nachher im Content-Team vertreten sind.
Wie viele Leute haben denn so Reviews?
Also technisch kündet sicherlich 30 Leute. Mindestens 30 haben mittlerweile einen Account. Aber nicht jeder macht alle Vorträge. Es ist eine Frage der Kompetenz.
Ja, ist auch nicht zu schaffen. Also ist vielleicht zeitlich zu schaffen, wenn man viel Zeit hat. Aber genau, wie du schon sagst, man kennt sie ja nicht zu einem aus. Also wer kann schon immer irgendwie über Körne, Exploits und Fuzzing irgendwie klare Aussagen machen, ob das jetzt cool ist oder nicht.
Es geht aber auch gar nicht unbedingt immer nur bei den Inhalten. Manchmal geht es auch darum, okay, wie hat derjenige eingereicht, ist überhaupt verständlich, was er erzählen will. Oder gibt es da nur ein paar Folien und eine Überschrift, oder dann müssen wir halt nochmal nachfragen.
Ah, interessanter Punkt. Das hatte ich jetzt noch gar nicht auf der Liste, sondern vielleicht in der letzten Stelle mal erwähnt. Sagt doch mal, also wenn man jetzt meint, ein Thema zu haben für den Kongress, wie sollte man seine Einreichung gestalten, damit das auch eine Chance hat gewürdigt zu werden? Darf ich nebenbei noch Tiramisu essen? Du bist ja schon fattig, ne?
Mhm, Tim hat mich mit Tiramisu bestochen, das ist natürlich super gemein.
Ich hab noch was Ure, willst du noch was haben?
Nee, danke, das war aber sehr lecker.
Okay, dann leg mal los, ich mampfe mal ein bisschen.
Also für den Prozess, wenn man jetzt derjenige ist, der mal einreichen will, dann sollte man zunächst überlegen, wie wäre es auf der anderen Seite zu stehen und sich zu überlegen, welche sinnvollen Informationen sollte man geben. Das heißt, alle Felder, die wir so abfragen in dem Submission-Formular, also in dem Einreichungsformular, die sollten erstmal ausgefüllt sein.
Sollten gewürdigt werden.
Manche setzen einfach nur eine Überschrift und schreiben ihren Namen dazu und sagen, wir schreiben in den Notes dann so was wie Rest kommt später.
Rest kommt später ist ganz schlecht, oder?
Ja, ganz schlecht. Ganz schlecht. Also wir haben auch gewisse Fristen, die wir einhalten müssen, weil wir machen die Proceedings ja dann auch und wir müssen den Fahrplan fertigstellen, wir müssen allen Leuten Bescheid sagen, die angenommen oder nicht angenommen sind. Wir brauchen halt Zeit, wir können nicht warten bis in Dezember. Das läuft schon immer im August, im September und im Oktober, diese ganze Prozess. Und entsprechend ist er natürlich schlau, möglichst vollständig und auch vielleicht nicht, also in ganzen Sätzen und dramatikalisch und rechtschreibt technisch korrekt.
Und vor allem in der Sprache, in der man den Vortrag zu halten gedenkt.
Ja, auch noch mal wichtig, aber wobei das nicht so schlimm ist. Das entscheidet ja nicht.
Das fand ich aber ein bisschen absurd, dass manche Leute halt so sagen, ja kann ich auch in Englisch machen und da war halt alles in Deutsch. Das Problem ist, selbst wenn man den dann annimmt, was dann wahrscheinlich nicht stattfindet, aber wenn man ihn dann annimmt, dann wartet man dann als Team ewig darauf, dass dann noch einmal die englische Beschreibung kommt. Und da steht dann, wenn sie dann überhaupt mal kommt, was ganz anderes drin. Also zum Zeitpunkt der Abgabe sollte man echt darauf achten, dass wirklich alles drin ist.
Also es lohnt sich halt nicht.
Wie war so die Qualität der Einreichungen in der Hinsicht? Also formal?
Ich würde sagen, man muss bei etwa so bei 20 Prozent nochmal ein Äquiposit nachfragen. Also wo wir es erstmal interessant finden, dann schicken wir jetzt mal mehr raus und sagen, hey, hier fehlt noch was oder das interessiert uns erst mal, aber kannst du mal noch ein bisschen mehr sagen? Es sind nicht so viele.
Naja, es sind immerhin schon 40, ne?
Ja, es kommt so ungefähr hin. Also wir verteilen diese Koordinierung auch. Also alle im Content-Team koordinieren auch. Das heißt, nehmen sich ein Subset, also einen bestimmten Anteil der Leute und koordinieren die. Stellen Fragen, geben den Informationen mit und so was. Und fragen halt zum Beispiel, wenn die Papers kommen sollen, dass die Fristen eingehalten werden, dass es zum Beispiel nochmal Übersetzungen gibt, wenn jetzt da sprachliche Sachen sind oder so eine Sache. Es ist eigentlich so, dass man auch sagen kann, dass 20 Prozent eigentlich gleich hin runterfallen, weil so leere oder kaum mit Inhalt gefüllte Sachen sind, die offenbar so ohne viel nachdenken da so ins...
Mir schlagt man was vor.
Ja, ja, genau.
Verstehe.
Und dann gibt es natürlich auch noch einen Anteil von Leuten, die wir fragen, ob sie kommen. Das ist auch nochmal, denke ich mal vielleicht so, ein Drittel ist vielleicht ein bisschen viel, aber auch nochmal so 20, 30 Leute, die wir ansprechen, weil wir sie gerne hätten und weil sie bestimmte Themen haben, die uns interessieren, also das ist ein bisschen einmal die Einreichung, aber andererseits auch Leute anwerben. Denn zu manchen Themen haben wir nichts, d.h. da kommt keine Einreichung, wir möchten aber unbedingt ein Thema auf dem Kongress haben und da muss man natürlich dann Leute finden, die da interessante Sachen zu erzählen oder da irgendwie zu forschen oder was hacken können oder derart.
Ich stelle gerade fest, das wird glaube ich ein ganz schön voller Kongress. Weil der Kongress Donnerstag, Freitag, Samstag und Sonntag ist.
Na klar, ist doch sexy.
Na das ist total. Also ich weiß noch, als das letzte Mal so war, das war nämlich der 19C3, da war echt eine Menge los mit Tagesgästen. Oh weia, das BCC wird platzen. Letztes Jahr hatten wir 4200 Leute.
42, ich meine 4200.
Und weißt du was? Jetzt stimmt es sogar. Wir hatten ja schon immer mal so leicht.
Jetzt haben wir es im Radio gesagt, jetzt stimmt es.
Ja, es stimmt, es war. Es war echt wahr. Also das heißt Personen, das heißt nicht, dass die alle gleichzeitig da waren, weil dann hätte man ein Sicherheitsproblem, sondern es gibt halt Tagesgäste, die kommen halt irgendwie am Tag, dadurch relativiert sich das. Aber es ist natürlich schon so, dass immer gewesen, der große Teil sind einfach Dauergäste. Das finde ich überhaupt cool am Kongress, einfach die meisten Leute, die da sind, sind einfach immer da. Und das merkt man halt auch an der Atmosphäre.
Na klar. Es ist ja tatsächlich so ein Community-Eignis. Also ich persönlich freue mich auch immer, weil ich viele Leute, die ich das ganze Jahr über nicht sehe, vielleicht mal chatter oder telefoniere. Aber ich freue mich dann echt auch, die mal in einem realen Leben zu treffen. Das ist toll. Ja, es ist oft so, dass man die Leute trifft, die man wirklich noch nie gesehen hat, wie, hm, deswegen mal legen, weil grad, wie wir das vielleicht auch mit freiwilligen Namensschildern machen, hat man ja Bock halt so, ähm, wegen dem Flirtfaktor.
Mellie17 has a crush on you. Bevor wir uns jetzt zu sehr hier in Details verlieren, verlieren wir uns, glaub ich, lieber in den Details der Vorträge. Wir haben ja diesmal sechs Kategorien. Den klassischen Kategorien Hacking, Science, Society, Culture und Community ist jetzt noch die Kategorie Making hinzugefügt worden oder, sagen wir mal, ein bisschen mehr ausgegliedert worden, weil das war vorher immer so in Hacking mit drin. Das war, glaub ich, so ein bisschen das Bedürfnis, das zu unterscheiden. Das heißt, wir wollen auch weiterhin betonen, dass es eben auch darum geht, einfach mal Konkretes zu schaffen und nicht nur daherzureden. Aber ich würde sagen, wir fangen einfach mal an im Hacking-Bereich, weil das ist ja nun so die klassische Geschichte. Das sind halt alles Sachen, die jetzt wirklich auch computertechnisch sind, wo es um Programmieren geht, wo es auch, aber nicht im Wesentlichen, um Security geht. Viele Leute haben ja immer noch dieses Bild so Hacking, das ist so dieses, ich kann es gar immer hören, in den Computer eindringen. Damit hat es nichts zu tun, sondern es geht einfach ums Konkrete tun und machen mit Technik. Das ist eigentlich das Ding, wobei das Machen jetzt vielleicht eher ins Making ausgegliedert ist im Sinne von wir tun, ja, hart wäre was, aber ehrlich gesagt, wenn ich mir so die derzeitige Gliederung anschaue, sind das fließende Übergänge.
Ja, das ist manchmal nicht so trendscharf.
Aber das geht eben auch nicht so ohne Weiteres.
Nee, und wir überlassen es in der Regel eigentlich auch, den Referenten selbst zu entscheiden, nur bei krassen Fehlentschätzungen ändern würde das. Also die Referenten entscheiden da schon selber.
Na, womit fangen wir denn mal an?
Wir fangen einfach oben an.
Wir fangen oben an, okay.
Genau, weil da kommt ein interessanter Vortrag.
Das heißt, die Reihenfolge, die wir jetzt haben, ist ein bisschen beliebig. Es geht jetzt ein bisschen bunt durcheinander. Aber wir bleiben zumindest erstmal in der Kategorie Hacking.
Also der Vortrag ist von Arianne Wijn, obwohl ich nicht sicher bin, wie man holländisch den Nachnamen ausspricht, da bin ich immer nicht sicher.
Sag einfach den Titel des Vortrags.
How to find a special one out of millions. Du bringst jetzt sozusagen vom Start gleich alles durcheinander.
Jetzt haben wir hier so eine tolle Liste gemacht und versuchen das so, hey, wir machen das jetzt mal so ganz spontan, damit keiner das merkt, wie gestaged das hier alles ist.
Es ist Tenji Monitoring Live, Entschuldigung.
Ich konzentriere dich nochmal ein bisschen. Bist du sicher, dass du dich noch was von dem Tiramisu haben möchtest?
Ja, deswegen, weil ich dir die ganze Zeit beim Tiramisu zugucken muss. Na jedenfalls, worum es in dem Vortrag geht, ist mal ganz interessant.
Welchen denn jetzt eigentlich?
Also Tenji Monitoring Live heißt er jetzt.
Ji heißt?
Hier geht es um Daten im Ethernet, also Gigabit.
Gigabit Ethernet. Genau. 10 GE ist sozusagen das, was wir alle noch nicht haben. Richtig scheiße viele Daten, so was gibt es nur in Backbones. Und jemand behauptet, er könnte sich das Live alles angucken.
Und analysieren. Das ist halt sicherlich nicht einfach.
Ein Gigabyte pro Sekunde heißt das quasi.
Das ist ziemlich fett.
Das ist echt eine Menge Daten. Okay.
Und die geht es also darum, dass er versucht, wegzuschmeißen, was er nicht braucht, um das sinnvoll analysieren zu können. Ich habe eine ähnliche Anlage mal gesehen, und zwar unten im CERN, also unten in Genf, da bauen die gerade so was für ihre Apparaturen. Die würden sich sicherlich über diese Software freuen. Also wir sind gespannt, was da kommt. Das ist auch so, das ist der erste Mal, dass wir so was hören. Ich werde jetzt bemühen, die Titel vorzutragen, und nicht die Untertitel, ich weiß auch nicht.
Das ist übrigens auch so ein Ding, also das lohnt sich immer noch mal da durchzugehen. Häufig sind nämlich bei Einreichungen, die Titel sind immer so fetzige, coole Namen, die aber einfach mal nichts darüber aussagen, worum es geht. Und im Untertitel steht dann eigentlich der Titel. Ich bin immer dazu übergegangen.
Find the Special One Out of Millions gar nicht so schlecht, oder?
Das ist ein typischer Untertitel, oder?
Das ist der Untertitel zu dem Vortrag eben.
Alles klar, okay, das ist gut sortiert.
Also wir müssen vielleicht noch mal einen Satz über die Auswahl sagen, die wir jetzt treffen, die ziemlich, wie soll ich sagen, die ist halt irgendwie...
Wir haben uns jetzt einfach mal hier so keine Ahnung, wie viel Prozent des Vortrags geschnappt, um das einfach mal zu erwähnen. Aber wir müssen jetzt auch nicht unbedingt immer in die totale Tiefe gehen. Nächste, was ich hier habe, ist Crouching PowerPoint Hidden Trojan.
Ja, und ich vermute es schon wieder in holländischem Namen, weiß ich aber nicht genau. Martin von Horenbeek. Hier geht es mal ein bisschen darum, wie hat sich diese Trojane-Geschichte entwickelt in den letzten Jahren, so etwa 2005 würde ich darüber sprechen. Was sind heute die Attacken, die gefahren werden, wie komplex sind die? Das wird sicherlich sehr interessant, wenn man auch mal ein bisschen über die Zeit gucken kann. Man hat jetzt ja schon ein paar Monate...
Also sozusagen ein Überblick darüber, security-technisch, wie sich Trojane, jetzt konkret Trojane...
Welche Attacken werden da gefahren? Und natürlich auch ein bisschen, wie man die abwehren kann. Und welche Exploit-Techniken werden eigentlich verwendet? Das denke ich auch interessant.
Aber jetzt beides auch neue Referenten, ne?
Ja, das heißt aber nichts. In der Regel ist es schon so, dass Teilnehmer im Content-Team schonend Kontakte haben.
Achso, so wollte ich das jetzt auch gar nicht darstellen. Es sind jetzt auch wirklich Vortragende, die wir noch nicht gehabt haben. Das ist ja auch was Gutes. Es gibt ja auch immer wieder so diese Vorwürfe. Da kommt ja immer das Gleiche und immer die gleichen Leute erzählen, was dem ist einfach gar nicht so. Also wir hatten eigentlich in den letzten Jahren immer wieder eine ganz gute Durchspülung. Und es ist auch sehr interessant zu sehen, wer halt auch immer wieder neu zum Kongress so dazustößt.
Irgendwie, wenn wir so anziehen. Also wer auch von selbst manchmal auf uns zukommt, wo wir immer sagen, wow.
Okay, womit geht es weiter? Was kannst du noch empfehlen?
Na, wir wollten auch darüber reden, dass, wenn wir jetzt die alphabetische Liste haben, dass Roger Dingle dann wiederkommt. Also der Kopf des Tor-Projekts. Der Tor-Onion-Router, also der Anonymisierungsdienst. Da freuen wir uns. Und in diesem Jahr wird es so sein, dass eigentlich nicht so ein allgemeiner Tor-Vortrag von Roger gehalten wird, sondern dass es mehr darum gehen soll, sich auszutauschen. Er hat es überschrieben mit Come Talk with Roger. Also darum gehen soll, sich zu unterhalten und einfach mal Ideen und Zukunft. Das finden wir sehr wichtig. Er wollte mit Absicht auch nicht einen großen Talk, sondern einen kleineren.
Schon fast mehr ein Community-Talk als ein Hacking-Talk. Sollten wir vielleicht noch eine andere Kategorie schmeißen.
Du mit deinen Kategorien.
Ja, na ja, wenn man sie schon hat, sollte man sie auch benutzen. Auch wenn das immer nicht so einfach ist.
Genau, wo wir dringend jedem Möchtegern, Hacker und Hacker empfehlen wollen hinzugehen, sind Desperate House Hackers. Genau, es geht nämlich um Pfandflaschenrücknahmeautomaten.
Alles klar, diese Drehteller-Maschinen, die im Supermarkt stehen.
Wir fanden die Idee auch irgendwie so krude und lustig, dass wir gesagt haben, das wollen wir wirklich mal hören. Da sind wir schon gespannt. Das ist jetzt nicht im Großen Saal, aber ich glaube, das wird ernst interessant.
Okay, Nils Magnus, ein bekannter Name, auf jeden Fall.
Ja, auf jeden Fall, Nils Magnus.
Sowas finde ich mal gut. Man muss sich auch nicht mal alles so ernst nehmen.
Dann nehmen wir als Nächstes, so interessant ist vielleicht noch der Talk von Svenja Schröder. I know who you clicked last summer. Hier würde es ein bisschen darum gehen, die Daten aus sozialen Netzwerkplattformen zu analysieren, man anzugucken. Also was kann man daraus eigentlich machen?
Also sozusagen Daten...
Genau, also grafentheoretisch ist das auch in diesem Fall.
Datenspur-Analyse sozusagen.
Fanden wir auch recht interessant. Also so die typischen Plattformen wie MySpace und Facebook und vielleicht auch Studi4Z.
Und ist auch ein Mädel, was vorträgt?
Ja genau, Svenja war schon mal bei uns.
War schon mal da. Aber es sind auch wieder so einige Mädels am Start, dies Jahr.
Svenja ist sogar ziemlich bekannt, weil Svenja hat das Mädchen-Blog.
Das Mädchen-Blog?
Kann man mal nachklicken. Mädchen-Blog.
Kommt in die Linkliste.
Da kennen wir nix.
Klar, da kennen wir nix.
Worüber können wir noch reden, was interessant ist?
Podscanning Improved fällt mir gerade noch ins Auge.
Wir sollten dringend über Podscanning Improved reden, weil es ist ein Vortrag von FX.
FX auf Phenolid. Congress Insider, ein wohlbekanntes Recht.
Da wird es um Podscanning gehen, wie der Teeplü schon sagt. Und zwar New Ideas for Old Practices. Er wird vor allem auch mal erklären, warum sie sich mit dem Thema Podscanning befassen. Wo man ja sagen könnte, es ist ein alter Hut.
Aber so wie ich FX kenne, hat er sich da wieder was hickes Neues einfallen lassen.
Was sieht es aus? Wir gehen davon aus, dass er da coole Sachen zu sich gibt.
Ja, FX ist ja ein Oldschool-Teilnehmer eigentlich beim Kongress. Er hat eigentlich fast bei jedem Kongress immer wieder interessante Vorträge. Ich glaube nicht bei jedem, weil wenn er nichts zu erzählen hat, dann hält er nämlich auch das Maul.
Na, er hat diesen coolen Blackberry-Vortrag, der war natürlich irgendwie sehr schön. Und er kann mich auch noch gut an seinen Auftritt bei der literarischen Codequartette erinnern. Er hat eine persönliche Art, die etwas gefühltungsbedürftig ist, aber die meisten schätzen doch seine Talks.
Ja, in dem Zusammenhang kann ich auch mal ein Chaosradio Express-Nummer, habe ich vergessen...
Oh nein, du weißt wieder die Nummer nicht....
hinzuweisen, wo es um Windows-Security ging, den ich mit FX gemacht habe. Das war Nummer 22, CRE022, wo er erklärt, warum Vista jetzt allen Security-Leuten so viel Kopfschmerzen macht. Und so ist es übrigens auch, wie ich letzte Woche in Wien auf der DeepSec-Konferenz habe verstellen dürfen. Es waren alle total frustriert.
Und wer FX mal von der lustigen Seite kennenlernt, der kann sich ja unser letztjähriger PowerPoint-Karaoke holen.
Aber war er nicht etwas angeheitert?
Ja, er war etwas angeheitert, aber ist durchaus lustig anzusehen. Wir haben nachher noch einen Talk von FX, obwohl wir ihn gleich besprechen können. Er hat nämlich noch einen zweiten Vortrag. Er wird da reden über die Barcodes.
Toying with Barcodes.
Diese Strichmuster werden wahrscheinlich die meisten kennen.
Ja, gibt es auf jeder Milchtüte.
Wie kann man die denn manipulieren und wie kann man damit spielen? Das ist ganz interessant. Ich war schon gespannt. Das haben wir ihnen natürlich in den großen Saal gerne gegeben, wenn wir sicherlich alle viel gute Unterhaltung haben. Jetzt aber genug der FX-Werbung. Wobei man ja...
Nicht genug Werbung machen kann.
Nein, für FX nicht.
Wir sind alle deine Fans. Oh Gott, hoffentlich kriegen wir Freikarten. Auch auf der Liste der Security-Sachen fällt mir gerade ins Auge. Ruhe on Rails, Security. Ruhe on Rails ist ja sehr verbreitet. Ist ja so ein bisschen auch die treibende Kraft des ganzen Web 2.0-Wahnsinns. Das finde ich sehr gut, dass das Thema einen Platz gefunden hat. Und dann sehe ich hier auch noch einen Klassiker, Security Nightmares. Hätte man eigentlich am Ende des Podcasts vielleicht packen müssen, weil ist ja eigentlich immer der traditionelle letzte Talk.
Ja, ist ja auch diesmal wieder so fast.
Vor der Abschlussveranstaltung.
Wer macht die übrigens, Tim?
Also ich habe eben gerade gesehen, dass ich da drin stehe.
Hoch? Ja, das wird zwar so sein. Ja, ich bin da ganz fest überzeugt.
Na, dann bin ich mal gespannt.
Und ich kann nur jedem empfehlen, sowohl zum Opening- wie auch zum Closing-Event zu kommen, weil es wird auch ein Augenschmaus.
Ich sehe schon. Mein Tiramisu hat gewirkt. Ja, also die Öffnungsveranstaltung, wir werden uns noch ein bisschen was einfallen lassen. Denn es soll ja auch ein spaßiger Konkurs sein. Nee, da sagen wir nichts drüber, weil wir wollten ja über Security Nightmares reden. Security Nightmares ist ein Traditionstalk. Jetzt müssen wir da alle weghören, die schon immer auf dem Kongress waren. Die werden das wissen. Ron und Frank sind immer dabei. Der Untertitel ist ja, worüber wir im nächsten Jahr lachen werden. Das ist sozusagen der Blick in die Glaskugel, aus der Beobachtung, der Hacker-Szene, sage ich jetzt mal, weil die beiden fassen ja im Prinzip auch immer zusammen, was wir kollektiv immer alle schon so empfinden. Es ist immer so, diese neue Technologie kommt auf die Bühne, findet eine bestimmte Verbreitung und man weiß immer schon so, oh weia, wenn sie jetzt anfangen, das und das zu machen. Was weiß ich hier, so Fingerabdrucksysteme bei Edeka, was wir ja gerade hatten. Wenn das erstmal in allen Supermärkten steht, was ist dann? Weiß der Geier, wie das mit Barcodes läuft, wenn FX mit seinem Vortrag fertig ist. Aber es gibt einfach so Sachen, das sind einfach Sollbruchstellen. Darum geht es, es geht um technische Sollbruchstellen in der Gesellschaft, weil wieder irgendjemand beschlossen hat, man müsste jetzt mal diese unausgereifte Technologie zur Anwendung bringen. Und was ich ja mal ganz interessant wäre, wäre ein Vortrag vorher, wo sie irgendwie vielleicht mal die Thesen des letzten Jahres abhangen.
Machen sie das? Ja, am Anfang haben sie immer die Thesen vom letzten Jahr und gucken, was ist eigentlich wahr geworden. Ich muss hier mal eine Hintergrundinformation liefern. Ich könnte vor zwei Jahren die Gelegenheit...
Ich bin ungebildet, weil ich verpasse nämlich den Vortrag immer...
Den Closing.
Weil ich mich immer auf die Abschlussveranstaltungen vorbereite.
Warum muss ich das eigentlich machen? Ja, aber wir haben auch Videos und Audiodateien von den Talks. Das ist ja keine Ausrichtung.
Nee, das stimmt.
Ich muss jetzt hier aber noch folgende Hintergründe vorgeben. Ich habe vor zwei Jahren beobachtet...
Das ist aber jetzt nur unter uns.
Ja, wie Ron und Frank tatsächlich im Hinterzimmer eine Glaskugel geputzt haben. Das heißt, man kann davon ausgehen, dass sie tatsächlich eine haben. Das heißt, die Zukunftsvoraussagen, die da kommen... Also das ist natürlich keine Glaskugel, das ist eine Kristallkugel. Auch wenn hier Glaskugel steht. Das ist eine Kristallkugel und sie haben sie. Ich wollte es nur mal sagen.
Okay, das heißt, das stimmt auch alles.
Im Prinzip schon. Okay, sie haben jede der Sachen, die nicht wahr wurden. Aber sie brauchen dann eigentlich nur sagen, okay, dann waren wir halt ein Jahr zu früh.
Ja, tolle Ausrede. Das heißt, wir müssten eigentlich am Anfang des Talks auch noch die Voraussagen, die in den letzten drei Jahren alle nicht eingetroffen sind, von dem Talk vor vier Jahren. Wir kommen jetzt ins 100.
Eine Sache vielleicht noch, Security Nightmares ist immer so ein bisschen gemeinsam mit dem Publikum. Das heißt, man kann sich und die Ideen, die man hat, auf da hinbringen, das finde ich immer ganz schön am Ende vom Kongress zu haben.
Genau, und das sind immer auch diese Momente, wo der Kongress einfach mal anders ist als andere Veranstaltungen. Also wer auf dem Kongress schon mal war, der wird wissen, wovon wir sprechen. Es gibt einfach ein anderes Verhältnis zwischen den Referenten und den Zuhörern. Also bei vielen Konferenzen gibt es immer so dieses, da ist immer so eine Glaswand dazwischen, der geheiligte Referent, der auserwählt, der kommt dann hin und präsentiert dann so seine Slides und dann wird er dann irgendwie artig beklatscht und danach fragt vielleicht mal einer was. Aber wenn beim Kongress jemand was Streitbares sagt, also was weiß ich hier, Lost the War war ein gutes Beispiel, also wenn man mit streitbaren Thesen daherkommt oder noch schlimmer einfach einen scheiß Vortrag hält, dann bricht in der Regel das Gewitter über ihn ein. Und dann geht es da einfach mal in den Diskurs. Und das ist eigentlich gut. Mir hat mal jemand gesagt, ich weiß nicht mehr, wer es war, irgendjemand aus England, der meinte so, einen Vortrag auf den Kongress halten, das ist schon so ein bisschen die Kür, weil er kennt keine Konferenz, wo das Publikum so gut zuhört und so kritisch ist, über das, was man gesagt hat. Das schätzen viele auch. Das ist nicht unbedingt etwas, was die Leute davon abhält, einen Vortrag zu machen, aber zumindest eine besondere Herausforderung steht da schon mit drin. Und sie wissen, dass sie einfach auch was liefern müssen.
Ich weiß aber, der Längerrand für Security Night ist so allgemeine Sachen nochmal.
Ja, da passt ja eine Menge rein. Das ist natürlich eine Traditionsveranstaltung, die es natürlich auch beim Kongress immer wieder geben muss. Ja, wir machen mal weiter. Aber es gibt ja noch mehr, was ja vorhin den Herrn Dingeldein schon erwähnt, es gibt ja noch mehr zum Thema Tor. Also zum Anonymisierer und so weiter, was ja auch, darf ich jetzt wieder eine Chaosradio-Sendung plagen? Chaosradio Express 51 war vor kurzem auch mit Anonymisierer, aber über Tor insbesondere so um die touristischen Begebenheiten wird es einen Vortrag geben.
Ja, und auch um so ein bisschen die Pläne, die der CCC in Zukunft haben wird. Und noch sogar die etwas weiteren Pläne, weil wir haben jetzt auch den ersten Vortrag zu I2P. Also der Vortrag heißt To Be or I2P.
Und I2P ist ein neues Anonymisierungssystem.
Genau, also ein Netzwerk, wo wir eigentlich meinen, dass das die Zukunft der Anonymisierungsdienste sein könnte. Und wo auch noch Mitstreiter gesucht werden. Das hat jetzt quasi noch so eine Beta-Phase. Und da, wenn wir jetzt von Jens Kubicki einen Vortrag haben, und mal horchen, wir hoffen auch, dass sich da vielleicht noch mehr Leute finden. Dass sich eine größere Community bildet, die daran mitwirkt. Aber wir werden auch als CCC einige zu Toren noch mal sagen, weil die ja im letzten Jahr eine Menge Vorfälle gab. Mit Räumung, Beschlagnahmung von Servern und so weiter.
Viele Leute fragen sich ja auch so, was für ein Risiko gehe ich ein, wenn ich selber einen Torsilver betreibe? Solche Fragen.
Ja, und was passiert eigentlich, wenn jetzt die Vorwärtsentsprechung in Kraft tritt? Wird das überhaupt noch legal sein? Wir wollen halt darüber sprechen und auch so ein bisschen gucken, wie wir als CTT da vielleicht helfen können. Das ist so ein bisschen der Plan. Also da gibt es dann, wie gesagt, eigentlich drei Vorträge zur Analyse.
Ist das noch geheim?
Nö, das ist nicht wirklich geheim, aber ich würde die Referenten nicht irgendwie...
Du wolltest ja nicht alles vorher erzählen, ne?
Genau.
Schließlich werden sie alle schlecht bezahlt.
Genau, überhaupt nicht eigentlich. Übrigens, also überhaupt keiner wird bezahlt.
Genau, es wird mit keiner bezahlt.
Kein Referent, keine Orger, keine Engel, niemand vom Kassensystem, niemand von der Referentenbetreuung, keiner der in Furtresen sitzt. Hab ich noch vergessen, niemand der im Hinterzimmer...
Es ist ein Prinzip des... Ich meine, wir hatten so einige Prinzipien. Manche haben wir auch schon wieder über Bord geworfen. Es gab auch mal so eine irrige Zeit, wo wir dann irgendwie Referenten haben, Eintritt zahlen lassen, das sind so Sachen, die wir nicht mehr tun. Ja, doch, wie auch immer. Das schwierige Thema ist, dass wir uns schon natürlich um Referenten bemühen. So werden wir es uns eben auch leisten können. Begutungen zahlen, Reisekosten usw. Viele tragen ihre Reisekosten trotzdem. Leute würden es nicht auch selber tragen können. Teilweise wäre das Angebot so auch überhaupt nicht zu leisten, weil der Kongress ist Low Budget und soll es natürlich auch bleiben.
Unkommerziell in jeder Hinsicht.
Genau. Bannerfrei, ständefrei. Mich nervt immer bei anderen Konferenzen, dass man reinkommt und sich erst mal vor wie auf der CeBIT. Das versuchen wir natürlich zu vermeiden. Aber jetzt wollen wir mal wieder auf die Themen einschwenken. Aber wir werfen halt immer mal wieder so ein bisschen Anekdoten.
Wollen wir kurz was sagen zu Smartcard-Protokollsniffing von Danfix?
Ja, natürlich.
Weil es gab ja da ein paar interessante Entwicklungen.
Ach, das ist die Sache in der Schweiz, ne? Genau.
Und da gab es diesen Postcard-Hack.
Postcard, ah ja, genau, richtig.
Da wird ein bisschen drüber erzählt. Das ist sicherlich sehr interessant, wenn man sich mal die Protokoll da genauer ansieht.
Danfix ist ja alter CCC-Mitstreiter. Wenn man mal auf das Dossier-Kaotik blickt, da gibt es so ein paar uralte Sachen aus den 80er Jahren. Sehr schöne Statements, da merkt man auch die alte Kultur, die von Vau und Steffen nach außen getragen wurde. Dass man halt auch seine Themen professionell vermitteln muss. Da konnten sie ja nichts für. Vau hatte immer die gleiche. Auf jeden Fall zu diesen komplexen Smartcard-Geschichten mit Schwerpunkt Schweiz, wahrscheinlich wird Bernd was vortragen.
Da haben wir auch noch ein paar Überraschungen, die wir heute nicht besprechen können. Weil die noch nicht so sicher sind, aber die sind eigentlich schon sicher. Das neigte Publikum soll sich ja auch noch ein bisschen überraschen lassen.
Es gibt immer genug Überraschungen. Mein einziges konstantes Gefühl bei CCC-Veranstaltungen ist das Gefühl der Überraschungen. Ich war bisher immer überrascht. Von jeder einzelnen Veranstaltung.
Toll, oder?
Sogar die ich selber geplant habe, weil ich überrasch. Weil das immer so überraschend ist. Weil diese Dynamik, du hast vorhin schon die Engel erwähnt. Das kann man ruhig noch mal erwähnen. Was viele Leute auch nicht begreifen, ist, wie dieser Kongress entsteht. Der Kongress entsteht extrem dynamisch. Der wird in zwei, drei Tagen aufgebaut. Eigentlich so richtig erst in einem. Das heißt, die Leute kommen frisch vom Weihnachtsbaum, schlagen in Berlin auf. Innerhalb eines Tages wird alles finalisiert. Es gibt Dinge, die langfristig vorbereitet werden. Aber vor Ort geht alles ratzefatze. Der Punkt ist, es gibt eigentlich kein großes Team. Es gibt ein paar Leute, die, was wir schon gesagt haben, viele Leute beteiligen sich in den Monaten vorher am Content. Der steht dann irgendwann fest. Dann gibt es ein sehr kleines Team, das Organisatorisches leistet. Ein noch sehr viel kleineres Team, was während des Kongresses diese Organisation fortführt, die sogenannte Projektleitung. Die von der ganzen Veranstaltung nichts mitbekommen. Das ist eigentlich der undankbarste Job, es sei denn, man steht drauf. Die meisten der Tätigkeiten, die so vorbereitet wurden, werden dann eben von den Engeln wahrgenommen. Das sind Leute, die ganz normale Teilnehmer sind, die sagen, ich zahle jetzt zwar Eintritt, aber ich will jetzt nicht meine ganze Zeit nur mit rumnerden und reden oder was auch immer oder Vorträge gucken. Ich möchte auch etwas dazu beitragen. Die melden sich dann halt bei den Engeln. So organisiert sich dann die ganze Veranstaltung aus sich heraus. Das ist das Spirit.
Das klingt doch auch immer toll. Das hat so ein bisschen was von einem Ameisenhaufen. Wir haben zwar auch eine Ameisenkönigin, Julia, aber das hat so ein bisschen von vielen kleinen...
Genau, und das überrascht mich immer wieder. Diese Dynamik und dieses totale, vor allem egal was man sich vorher für Gedanken macht, wie der Kongress vielleicht sein könnte. Man ist dann immer wieder überrascht, weil einfach so diese irre Dichte, die sich dann auf einmal so entfaltet, so wurknallmäßig auseinanderschleudert, alle mit ihren verrückten Stimmungen und irgendwie so, ja, und endlich wieder ist ein Jahr rum, geil, Kongress, es geht los, lass mal hier irgendwie Wahnsinn machen. Und so geht das dann vier Tage irgendwie ab und danach ist man total gescheitert und fragt sich, was war denn das jetzt schon wieder? Großartig. Ich bin ein Freund des Kongress. Themen, wir haben noch was im Hacking-Bereich, da wird mal wieder auf der Xbox rum.
Ne, wir müssen mal eh Trecker fahren, dürfen wir nicht vergessen.
Trecker fahren?
Trecker fahren. Wir haben da drei interessante Berliner Chaoten, die werden über ihren offenen Beton-Trecker berichten.
Genau.
Da gibt es eine Menge auch Anekdoten und da haben wir ja das Chaosradio auch schon, ne, der Express.
Genau, der letzte, der jetzt zu diesem Zeitpunkt, wo wir drüber reden, leider noch nicht veröffentlicht ist, aber das wahrscheinlich schon sein wird, zu dem Zeitpunkt, wo ihr dieses hört, hoffentlich. Aber in dem Vortrag geht es dann halt vor allem ganz konkret um die Technik und so weiter, wie das alles funktioniert und wird andersaufbereitet.
Du hast doch hoffentlich bei dem anderen Chaosradio dann den Open-Trecker-Blog verlinkt, oder? Gut, weil das ist ein ziemlich lustiges Blog. Ja, das kann man auch lesen, weil man vielleicht nicht so ein offener Beton- und Trecker-Fan ist.
So, aber dann war noch was mit der Xbox.
Der Herr Michael Steil kommt wieder. Er ist ja schon einer von den häufigeren Besuchern, den wir auch immer besonders gerne sehen.
Der immer wieder berichtet, wie er die nächste Spielkonsole aufmacht. Aber Xbox 360 war doch schon mal. Was ist da jetzt neu?
Ja, er wird ein bisschen mehr erzählen, vor allen Dingen zu der Sicherheitsarchitektur, wie sie jetzt da gebaut ist und wie das mit dem Hecken eigentlich funktioniert hat. Und wie man Lennox draufkriegt und so, das ist ganz sexy. Ich hab mich mit ihm jetzt länger unterhalten, der ist ja gerade nicht in Deutschland, obwohl er in Deutschland ist, aber er kommt extra für uns angeflogen.
Er ist glaube ich immer da.
Ja, er kommt extra her.
Jaja, aber er ist halt auch so Stammgast. Also er ist auch Stammreferent in gewisser Hinsicht, weil er halt immer was Neues beizutragen hat. Auf jeden Fall komplett in Bekraft.
Er hat sich ein bisschen beschwert darüber, dass er nun mit einer Stunde klarkommen muss, aber er wird das schaffen.
Stimmt, er macht auch immer so gepolente...
Er hat noch einen Co-Referent, fällt mir gerade ein, der ist noch gar nicht eingetragen. Aber sie sind dieses Jahr zu zweit.
So sind sie fast immer.
Also da freuen wir uns schon drauf, das wird wieder schick.
Jetzt rutschen wir so langsam vom Hacking ins Making, auch wenn da die Übergänge fließend sind.
Ja, genau.
Sehr fließend finde ich zum Beispiel ihr das nächste, Open Street Map, das ist ja ein Projekt, das es schon seit längerer Zeit gibt. Das ist so, wir bauen uns unsere Google Maps selber.
Ja, das geht halt so um eine nicht-kommerzielle Konkurrenz zu diesem Teleatlas und Navtech, also zu diesen kommerziellen Kartensystemen, die irgendwie gerade so die Welt übernehmen. Denn Navigationsgeräte sind ja extrem am Markt, hätte ja niemand gedacht.
Making ist das also sozusagen von daher vor allem, weil es ja hier auch um die konkrete... Jeder kann selber mal was machen, weil ja jeder dann mit einem GPS-Receiver durch die Gegend ziehen kann, ganz konkret bei dem Projekt beitragen kann. Wie das funktioniert, kommt dann in den Vortrag.
Die Methoden und was da eigentlich für eine Community hinter steht, werden wir also bei diesem Open-Street-Map talk hören. Finde ich sehr schön, dass wir das dieses Jahr haben. Das steht auch da ja, drei Jahre alt.
Da haben wir hier noch passend zum Vortrag, zum Kongressthema haben wir hier dampfbetriebene Telegraphie, Steampower Telegraphie, da bin ich sehr gespannt, da sagen wir mal nicht so viel dazu, aber das Thema Steampunk wird an der Stelle konkret vertieft.
Ja, wir sollten nicht vergessen The History of Guerilla Knitting.
Ach, was ist denn das?
Also Rose White wird darüber berichten, was eigentlich Guerilla Knitting sein soll, oder Guerilla Knitting. Ob es einfach nur rumstricken in der Öffentlichkeit ist, oder ob es vielleicht Kunst ist.
So Flashmob-Style oder was?
Ja genau, und sie fordert explizit auf.
Das heißt, wenn ihr schon immer gerne gestrickt habt.
Kannst du stricken? Ich kann stricken.
Ich kann sogar weben. Und häkeln.
Häkeln kann jeder Kind.
Und nähen. Ich kann sogar mit der Maschine nähen. Und elektrisch.
Kannst du auch klöppeln?
Klöppeln? Ich glaube, das kann ich nicht.
Wow, hätte mich jetzt nicht gewundert, wenn du das auch noch könntest.
Klöppeln.
Kannst du Ziernähte an Tischtecken anbringen?
Das hab ich noch nicht gemacht. Sticken? Sticken kann ich.
Also, sehr geehrte Publikum, wir haben ganz neue Möglichkeiten. Tim ist einfach Mutkern.
Ich sag dir sowieso, Handwerkliches ist einfach mal Web 3.0. Es geht jetzt einfach mal um Konkretes. Hier Fabienne, die du sicherlich auch kennst, da hab ich erst vor ein paar Tagen besucht in ihrem Hacker-Space. Unglaublich, ja. Sie baut irgendwie, sie ist am Stricken wie eine Wahnsinnige. Ja, Fabienne strickt. Man muss sagen, Fabienne Zeyer ist einfach eine hochbegabte Hackerin, die einfach Audiotechnik, Elektronik bastelt, also den totalen Hardcore-Stuff macht. Aber dann strickt sie halt auch noch gerne. Das bringt sie jetzt gerade zusammen, indem sie Methoden entwickelt, wie sie ihre Elektronik in die Klamotten rein kriegt. Dann fängt sie halt damit an, auch das Stricken in ihrer Urform zu verstehen. Und fängt jetzt erst mal an zu spinnen. Das heißt, sie webt dann die Sachen direkt ein. Also so Glasfaserkabel direkt mit der Wolle spinnen. Und das dann wiederum und so weiter. Wir werden da hier auf diesem Vortrag gelautet. Das ist ja auch das mit dem Making. Und da passt auch sehr gut dazu der Vortrag von Brie Pettis. Do-it-yourself Survival Brie Pettis, der in diesen Tagen schon nach Berlin kommt. Da freue ich mich sehr, da ist ein ganzen Monat hier. Ist so der Videoblogger von Make Magazine. Einer aus dieser Make Magazine Crew, der schon auf dem Camp war, den ich auch vor kurzem in Wien getroffen habe.
Das Make Magazine kommt auch.
Ja, also er kommt und es kommen auch noch andere Leute. Welcher denn?
Ich hab den Namen leider vergessen, aber er ist schon offiziell akkreditiert als Presse.
Ist das der Marc Fraunfelder?
Kannst nicht mehr sagen. Ich hab den Namen noch nicht im Kopf.
Steig das einmal nach. Wie auch immer. Die Jungs sind auf jeden Fall da. Die machen ja auch noch dieses zweite Magazin, dieses Craft-Magazin, wo ja auch schon so dieser Schritt zum wir gehen jetzt wirklich zu handwerklichen Sachen geht. Also es ist überhaupt eine Renaissance des Selbermachens. Ist derzeit einfach ganz klar, sondern es war auch schon auf dem Camp ganz deutlich. Es wird einfach mehr gebastelt und ganz normale Dinge, ganz normales Handwerk und wenn es stricken ist, kommt jetzt irgendwie mit rein ins Spiel und verbreitert die Anwendungspalette. Wir sind begeistert. Also den Vortrag von Brie Petters kann ich sehr empfehlen, weil Brie Petters einfach ein total netter Typ ist. Und der macht coole Sachen.
Der Senior Editor heißt Philip Taron.
Ah, Philip Taron kommt. Vorragend. Der hätte auch noch mal einen Vortrag machen sollen.
Der macht super Vorträge.
Wir haben auch noch ein Making, vielleicht das letzte. Wir werden diesmal auch mal einen Bericht haben. Wir haben ja jedes Jahr jetzt eigentlich schon, ich weiß gar nicht, wann wir angefangen haben, mit dem Streaming von Filmen. Bestimmt schon drei Jahre. Musst du vielleicht wissen, wann wir angefangen haben?
Also wir hatten schon viele Versuche, von denen manche gescheitert sind. Aber seit ein paar Jahren läuft es halt ganz gut. Und diesmal wird es auch einen Bericht geben, so wie es zum Networking ein Review gab.
Wir haben sogar diesmal zwei unterschiedliche Streamings, also zwei Alternative quasi, die man anklicken kann.
Also es gibt Streaming und viel wichtiger, also Streaming ist nicht unwichtig, aber ich finde ja an sich wichtiger noch Recording, damit auch dieses Mal alle Kongressaufzeichnungen wieder bei Chaosradio auch als eigener Podcast verfügbar sind. Wie das für den 22C3 und 23C3 schon der Fall ist.
Ich würde mal erfahren, wie es eigentlich geht, also wie die gemacht wird. Das ist ja auch mal interessant für andere Veranstaltungen, dass man mal fährt, wie es eigentlich läuft. Wollen wir mal zu Science übergehen?
Genau, gehen wir doch zu Science über. Das ist unsere dritte Kategorie. Science ist so ein bisschen, vielleicht sollten wir auch noch mal ein bisschen was dazu sagen, was mal so der Gedanke war, weil wir uns diese Kategorien mal haben einfallen lassen, war es ja überhaupt sehr schwierig, worüber handelt es sich, worüber, was macht denn dieser Kongress überhaupt, was ist denn unser Angebot? Und Science ist natürlich sehr nah dran an dem Hacking, aber hier geht es eigentlich auch um Sachen, die so ein bisschen akademischeren Touch haben, wo es wirklich auch um Sachen geht, die genauso auch auf akademischen Veranstaltungen ihren Platz haben könnten.
Genau.
Das ist ja auch so dein Bereich, dann kannst du ja gleich mal ein bisschen was sagen. Ja, wo wir mal anfangen.
Ich würde ganz gerne kurz über Computersimulationen als Prognose- und Planungsinstrumenten reden.
Ja, mach mal.
Das ist ganz interessant, ein Vortrag von Bianca Dreferl, die wird mal so ein bisschen erzählen, was eigentlich momentan für Computersimulationen was gibt, also wie der aussieht mit der künstlichen Intelligenz, wie weit die da sind.
Ja, Grenzen und Möglichkeiten kalkulierbarer Zukunft und dynamischer Planspiele.
Ja, das ist ein bisschen eine wissenschaftliche Herangehensweise. Sie ist bei uns so eine Hombordonie.
Das gehört sicher auch so in der Science-Kategorie.
Das ist schon nicht ganz unwichtig. Man braucht schließlich heutzutage Computersimulationen, weil man viele Dinge einfach nicht mehr live testen.
Sie müssen jetzt in der Lage, eine ausführliche Zusammenfassung in den Vortragsrand zu machen, damit man schon fast auf den Kongress gelandet. Falls ihr mal einen Vortrag halten wollt, schreibt einfach mal, worüber ihr reden wollt.
Das hilft.
Also in diesem konkreten Fall hat sie eigentlich die Beschreibung, die lange erst nachgeliefert hat.
Tut mir leid, Tim.
All die Illusionen. Constanze. Das hätte so schön werden können.
Es ist schon so, dass in Science normalerweise die, das sind eigentlich die Leute, die sich oft sehr gute Einreichungen machen, die Sinn machen, also die sich vorher an den Kopf machen.
Die das Paperschreiben auch gewöhnt sind.
Genau, und die auch manchmal schon fertige Paper abgeben. Insofern, es stimmt schon. Ja, wir freuen uns einfach, dass Bianca kommt.
By the way, wird es denn wieder ein Kongressband geben?
Das steht natürlich ganz fest. Da haben wir gestern erst so ein bisschen darüber unterhalten. Ich bin ja nicht so sehr am Orga-Team. Ich bin nur manchmal bei diesen Orga-Planungen dabei, um so ein paar Ideen beizusteuern. Da gehöre ich nicht so zum Kern. Da sind wir noch nicht so ganz... Wir haben aber vor allem über Namenszelle geredet. Das fand ich ganz interessant.
Über was?
Eine Namenszelle, ob man einen freiwilligen Namenszettel haben kann. Das fand ich ganz interessant.
Ja, das kann ja jeder machen.
Aber die Variante, die auf Bänder zu machen, ist halt ein bisschen teuer.
Na ja, wie auch immer. Das werden wir dann sehen. Namenszettel haben ja an sich schon Tradition, aber ich habe nie so gesehen, dass die wirklich...
Nein, ein paar machen das, aber viele nicht. Ich glaube, so ein Darmstädter lebt.
Vielleicht sollten wir so Leuchtbänder, Leuchtschriften, die so als Lauftext...
Das wird die Leute sexy finden.
Das ist wieder teuer. Das wird teuer. Wir sind weiter im Scientific-Bereich. Dann gibt es hier noch was, was extrem cool aussieht, von Maha. Linguistic Hacking. Maha erklärt, wie man eine Sprache erkennt. Wenn man das nicht versteht, was man rauskriegt, versteht das richtig, was für eine Sprache sich handelt und wie man herausfinden kann, was dort gesagt wird.
Der Kontext geht nicht nur um die Syntaxe, sondern auch um somantische Aspekte. Ich bin da sehr gespannt. Ihr kennt den Vortrag von Maha nicht. Maha ist einer der Professoren im CCC. Auch ein langjähriges Mitglied und auch beteiligt an der Planung des CCC. Wir sind da sehr gespannt. Der Vortrag heißt Linguistic Hacking.
Auch Maha gab es schon bei Chaosradio Express 41. Das kann ich sehr empfehlen. Sprachen war Hintergründe der Sprachforschung. Wikipedia ist natürlich auch dabei. Aber dieses Sprachending, da reden wir wirklich um Sprachen, wo kommen Sprachen her und so weiter. Wie hat sich das entwickelt? Warum ist Baskisch so komisch und so weiter?
Also wir sind da gespannt.
Cooles Thema und das wird sicherlich auch gut. Linguistic Hacking in Saal 1.
Na watten.
Watten wat. Was haben wir noch? Nee, Saal 2. Du hast gelogen.
Guck gerade mal. Oh, du hast recht, ist Saal 2. Es ist trotzdem doll.
Egal, hat eine Bühne.
Man muss zugeben, dass die meisten Science-Vorträge immer doch eher nicht so das ganz große Publikum sind. Sind ja oft die Hacking-Vorträge, die in Saal 1 sind. Oder die großen politischen Themen. Oder eben Community, was vor allen Dingen abends dann ist.
Jaja, man weiß es dann sowieso erst danach, was wirklich... Aber die Sex-Vorträge sind jetzt alle in Saal 1.
Die Sex-Vorträge sind alle in Saal 1, was glaubst du denn?
Dazu kommen wir noch. Leute, bleiben Sie dran, es geht später noch um Sex. Da lohnt es sich doch glatt, eingeschaltet zu bleiben. Wie machen die das im Fernsehen immer so? Legen sie nicht auf, schalten sie nicht aus, gehen sie nicht zur Waschmaschine, was sagen die da? Ich weiß nicht, ich sollte mal mehr Fernsehen gucken, dann könnte ich sowas auch spontan bringen. Wie auch immer. Wir haben weitere spannende Themen aus der akademischen Welt. Die ist eigentlich immer nicht so dafür bekannt, sexy zu sein.
Ich meine, ich arbeite in dieser Welt doch, da sind echt viele Dinge spannend, man denkt es gar nicht. Nur haben nicht alle immer so den, wie soll ich sagen, sie haben nicht immer so den Dreh raus für interessante Vorträge und ihren Content auch interessant zu bringen. Aber hier auf unserem Kongress haben wir die coolen Wissenschaftler.
Nehmen wir nur das Coolste vom Coolen.
Genau, das ist doch toll, oder?
Super, und da ist auch schon wieder was Cooles auf der Liste hier. Modelling Infectious Diseases in Virtual Realities. Ja, du wolltest immer noch darüber reden. Mich fasziniert das Thema. Das heißt, er redet darüber, wie man Plagen in Epidemien hat. Etablier, da gab es so einen Vorfall bei World of Warcraft. Darüber wird geredet.
Also wer dahin gehen mag und sich mal ansehen will, wie Modelling Infectious Diseases in Virtual Realities funktionieren kann, dem haben wir da in 2 einige zu bieten.
Ja, World of Warcraft war ja auch schon letztes Jahr ein Thema hier mit Joy Ito, der mal einen schönen Einblick gegeben hat, wie da so die Sozialstrukturen in solchen Welten sind. Das ist ja alles nicht uninteressant.
Also, den Vernehmen nach, müssen ja auch prozentual in deinen Hackern überdurchschnittlich viele World of Warcraft-Benutzer sein. Und mir persönlich sind doch einige Hardcore-Benutzer bekannt.
Ja, gab's auch schon welche, die hier schon bei Chaosradio Express waren.
Ach so, wer denn?
Na, der Dennis ist doch ein unverbesslicher World of Warcrafter. Also mittlerweile geht's wieder. Er hat da alles durchgespielt und dann war gut. Aber momentlang hatten wir das Gefühl, wir verlieren ihn.
Anyway, wir wollen auf den nächsten Vortrag hinweisen und zwar...
Jetzt wird's krass.
Quantum Cryptography.
Genau.
Wo Cryptography schon in den meisten Leuten ein Buch mit sieben Siegeln ist, gibt's jetzt nochmal das Ganze in Kompliziert.
So sieht's aus.
Aber wir hatten schon mal was zu Quantum Cryptography.
Oh ja, mehrfach. Auch schon theoretisch, aber auch schon ein bisschen praktischer natürlich.
Aber diesmal wird's noch praktischer?
Ja, dankenswerterweise kriegen wir auch ein bisschen Hardware, die drei Referenten mitbringen.
Ein Quantencomputer?
Ich werd da noch nicht zu viel verraten. Wir wollen ja auch die...
Schrödingers Katze. Die offizielle Hinrichtung einer Katze oder auch nicht auf der Bühne. Und das wird dann verschlüsselt.
Tim, wenn du jetzt noch ein bisschen Tiramisu hättest, würde ich es dir vielleicht sagen, aber...
Ich hab noch Tiramisu. Aber den ess ich selber.
Also, in jeden Fall erfüllen wir uns da sehr...
Okay, Quantenkryptographie wird spannend.
Genau, kann man auf jeden Fall sagen. Ja, und der letzte, den wir vielleicht noch vorstellen wollten, aus dem Bereich ist der Vortrag von Leon Hempel mit dem Titel Verteidige Sicherheit. Ja, das ist ja interessant, weil er so ein bisschen über Überwachungssysteme reden wird und über den Zusammenhang zwischen militärischer und nicht militärischer Technik und überhaupt um die Frage der Verantwortung. Also wenn man eben auf solche Systeme zurückgreift, ist das sehr interessant.
Kennst du den Referenten?
Ja, der hat unter anderem für meinen Buch einen Beitrag geschrieben. Und da muss ich sagen, finde ich es sehr schön, dass er Zeit gefunden hat. Er ist hier aus Berlin, aber dass er Zeit findet, mal so endlich zum Kongress zu kommen. Ich wollte ihn letztes Jahr schon einladen. Und er war auch in Dresden bei den Datenspuren und hat sich mit Videoüberwachung befasst. Da hat er sehr interessante Sachen aus London erzählt.
Die Tiramisu ist jetzt alle übrigens, also jetzt ist vorbei. Tiramisu ist alle, meinte ich. Ja, gut, meine sehr geehrten Damen und Herren, wir müssen uns jetzt leider... Okay, Datenspuren in die Linkliste machen. Heute schreibe ich mir alles mal mit, damit ich mir nicht alles nochmal komplett anhören muss. Das kostet einfach so viel Zeit, diesen Podcast. Ich weiß nicht, warum ich das überhaupt.
Weil es Spaß macht.
Stimmt, richtig, hat ich vergessen. Okay, dann lass uns weitermachen. Eine Kategorie, die wir erklären dürfen. Hier geht es um die Gesellschaft. Diese Kategorie gibt es, weil wir natürlich klassisch im Club Technik und Gesellschaft und insbesondere Auswirkungen auf die Gesellschaft durch die Anwendung von Technik haben. Society ist so eben das, wo es nicht so sehr jetzt um die Technik geht, sondern wo wir uns sehr viel mehr Gedanken darüber machen, wie es denn nun so ist mit der Gesellschaft. Also Bestandsaufnahmen der Gesellschaft, Studien, gesellschaftliche Zusammenhänge, Technikfolgen, solche Sachen. So, was haben wir da dieses Jahr?
Wir haben eine Menge und ich glaube, wir können jeweils ein paar Sitzchen sagen, weil sonst wären wir nicht mehr fertig. Also ich glaube, wir müssen ein bisschen kürzer machen.
Damit der Podcast noch vor dem Kongress rauskommt.
Ja, sonst reden wir hier bis zum 27. Dezember. Da brauchen wir eine Menge mehr Tiramisu.
Das stimmt, aber ich kann das ganz gut machen.
Hast du den selbst gemacht? Oh, liebe Hörer, ich habe Tiramisu von Tim selbst gemacht gegessen. Hammer!
Du hast Glück gehabt, dass noch was übrig war.
Eventuell sollten wir im Chaosradio-Shop etwas Tiramisu zum Klicken anbieten.
Brauchen wir erst mal einen Chaosradio-Shop, so weit sind wir noch nicht.
Ach stimmt, Details.
Okay, also was haben wir hier? Die 23 leuchteten mir entgegen. 23 Wege zu kämpfen, 23 Ways to Fight, das macht Markus Bekedahl von netzpolitik.org.
Er ist ja selber sehr erfolgreich in dieser Hinsicht, dass er versucht, sich da stark zu machen. Er wird uns also 23 Wege zeigen, wie man sich mit seinen eigenen Fähigkeiten und Talenten einbringen kann.
Für die Bürgerrechte. Wie man was tun kann. Und nicht immer nur reden, dass man alles scheiße findet, sondern dass man einfach ganz konkret Dinge tut.
Markus Bekedahl ist derjenige, der netzpolitik.org hat, also die ziemlich bekannte und, glaube ich, eines der meistgeklickten Blogs in Deutschland.
Der ist da ganz oben. Nicht zu unrecht.
Ganz genau. Ich finde es auch ganz toll, was er da macht. Er hat hier in Berlin einen kleinen New Thinking Store, wo viele Veranstaltungen sind. Also wir freuen uns immer, wenn Markus Zeit hat, bei uns einen Vortrag zu halten. Wann gibt es Filme? Wir haben überhaupt mal ein Nachtprogramm. Müssen wir mal kurz drüber reden.
Denn der Kongress fängt ja eigentlich erst immer so richtig an, um wann es die ersten Vorträge ist. Habe ich noch gar nicht geguckt. Um 11. Okay, wir haben den Zeitplan vom letzten Jahr. Das heißt, um genau zu sein, gehen normalerweise die Veranstaltungen los, mit der Ausnahme des ersten Tags, wo die Eröffnungsveranstaltung ist. Aber wir haben halt, wie soll ich sagen, Mitleid.
Ja, wir stehen nicht um neun Uhr. Was soll das denn?
Das funktioniert auch nicht.
Nein, warum?
Also wenn wir auch immer was um neun Uhr oder zehn Uhr hatten, das war einfach keiner da.
Warum sollen wir uns selber quälen, wenn die anderen immer um acht Begrüßungen um neun der erste Vortrag? Das ist so dämlich. Das können sie bei der BKA-Konferenz machen.
Genau. Kongress ist für Leute, die spät aufstehen. Die cool sind. Deswegen müsst ihr alle kommen.
Und deswegen feiern wir aber nicht weniger abends, nur, wenn ein bisschen später wird.
Nee, aber das heißt dann aber auch, dass Veranstaltungen, also so um null Uhr ist eigentlich normalerweise Vortragsschluss.
Ja, na ja, das stimmt ja nicht so.
Na ja, so Pi mal Daumen. Aber dann gibt es halt noch Veranstaltungen danach, die dann aber in zunehmenden, fortgeschrittener Zeit immer nachtkompatibler werden. Also es wird immer entertainer, so mehr man sich sozusagen der Tagesgrenze oder der Morgengrenze viel mehr nähert.
Jedenfalls gibt es da schöne, panoptische Prinzip.
Ja.
Hier werden von Christine Ketzer und ihren Mitstreitern Kurzfilme gezeigt, die also bei diesem Minutenfilmwettbewerb vom Kölner Arkaus Computer Club gesammelt wurden. Ich denke, das wird sehr interessant. Kurzfilme sind ja sowieso mal sehr nett. Ich hab mir von Christine nur so ein bisschen erzählen lassen. Und sie sagt, da sind echt ein paar Schmankerl bei.
Das geht zwei Stunden. Also da muss ja einiges angelaufen sein.
Ja, da gibt es natürlich auch, also sie werden auch schon sagen, was dazu klappt.
Schön, dann gibt es ja wieder Futter für ChaosTV.
Und kurz erwähnen, wir sollen nicht vergessen, dass wir natürlich auch uns mit dem Thema Vorratssatenspeicherung befassen. In dem Fall wird Eric von der IFF, also Eric Josison vortragen.
Von der Electronic Frontier Foundation, so in den USA, was den politischen Kampf betrifft, noch so das Vergleichbarste.
Aber das ist sozusagen der europäische Abgesandte. Da freuen wir uns sehr und da wird es um Data Retention und EuroDAC gehen. EuroDAC ist ja die Datenbank.
Das wusste ich auch schon mal, was das heißt. Genau, die Datenbank.
Die sehr große mittlerweile, glaubt ihr, schon 1999 beschlossen worden oder 2001, also schon sehr, sehr lange. Also da sind wir schon gespannt. Es geht im weitesten Sinne mit Überwachung.
Dann hab ich hier eine Constanze kurz.
Ja, wir werden...
Bundes-Treuern, also die unendliche Geschichte muss natürlich auch mal erwähnt werden. Machst du es zusammen mit Andreas?
Andreas ist ja derjenige, der für den CCC die Stellungnahme vom Verfassungsgericht gemacht hat. Das ist natürlich auch eine Gemeinschaftsarbeit. Wir haben einige mit dran gearbeitet, aber er war auch derjenige, der dahin gegangen ist und als Sachverständiger Stellung genommen hat. Und ich denke, die ganze Jahre haben wir über ein Bundes-Treuern gerät und wir werden hier noch mal eine Zusammenfassung versuchen zu geben.
Was eigentlich stand, weil es ist nämlich immer so, es kam wieder was und wieder was und wieder was. Das ist sozusagen ein Vortrag, der einfach mal sagen soll. Und das ist das, was bisher passiert ist.
Und wir haben den Bundes-Treuern natürlich dabei.
Das hübsche Pferdchen.
Das sieht aus, das ist echt toll. Nee, das hat ein Atemnehmer gefunden, das Bonnerhaus der Geschichte. Ach ne, echt?
Das wird jetzt schon eingemottet? Ich dachte, das wird jetzt noch über 100 Demos gezogen. Das ist schon ein alter Hut.
Das hat eigentlich schon ziemlich viele Kilometer hin. Wir waren doch in Karlsruhe damit.
Also du weißt, bevor es komplett auseinanderfällt überkonservieren, wird es dann so ein Plexiglas geglossen.
Eigentlich ist das noch, das ist sehr haltbar. Ja, das macht irgendwie einen guten...
Hast du das noch mal nachgemalt?
Ein bisschen, also in kleine Stellen. Also wenn man was abkratzt, dann wird es natürlich weiß, das zweite ist aus Podestirul. Also das letzte Mal kann man da den Bundes-Trojaner auch mal reiten. Oh, habe ich das gesagt? Das habe ich nicht gesagt, oder?
Nee, hast nicht gesagt.
Genau, wir sind unter uns, niemand hört uns. Okay, dann haben wir die Wahrheit und was wirklich passierte. Vortrag weiter, Vortrag von Frank und Ron, unser Dream-Team in puncto Security Nightmares.
Und Glaskugeln.
Genau, Kristallkugel. Ja, und sie werden ja so ein Konzept vorstellen, dass jede Geschichte...
Jede Geschichte hat vier Seiten, heißt es da.
Genau, die eine Seite, nämlich deine, ihre Seite, die Wahrheit und das, was wirklich passiert ist. Das ist halt so ein Konzept von Bruce Sterling, das nennt sich Major Consensus Narrative. Und sie werden auch erzählen, was dieser Major Consensus ist. Und ich glaube, das wird sehr unterhaltsam, sie haben das vor drei oder vier Jahren schon mal gemacht. Und ich glaube, da werden wir über einige Vorkommnisse in der letzten Zeit...
Saal eins.
Ja, genau.
Ganz klar.
Da es ja dieses Jahr keine Fnord Nu-Show gibt, ist vielleicht...
Das scheint ja ein guter Nachfolger zu sein.
Ja, es ist nicht wirklich ein Nachfolger, aber...
Aber ein Ersatzprogramm.
Genau. Und wir haben ja auch immer noch Hacker Jeopardy und so, da kommen wir ja noch zu. Also wir haben schon noch durchaus Veranstaltungen.
Meinst du, für die Folklore ist nach wie vor gesorgt?
Ja, dann haben wir Distributed Campaigns for Promoting and Defending Freedom in Digital Societies. Da folgen wir uns auch besonders drüber. Wir wollen uns hier vernetzen mit den Franzosen. Die haben eine sehr wirklich erfolgreiche Kampagne.
Wie man sozusagen global aktiv werden kann.
Genau, wie man sich vernetzen kann. Die haben ja einige Geschäfte in Bezug auf geistige Deigentum. War in Europa seinesgleichen sucht und hier wird, ich weiß jetzt nicht wie er heißt, die Abkürzung von seinem Namen ist nur... Ja, JZ oder Jay-Z, ich weiß nicht wie er jetzt heißt. Hab ihn aber schon mal getroffen, war schon mal in Berlin.
Okay, er hat einen Namen.
Er hat auf jeden Fall einen Namen, den er vielleicht auch nennen wird und da sind wir gespannt drauf. Von Frankreich lernen kann ja auch mal Siegen lernen heißen.
Ja, auf jeden Fall, die haben einen Eiffelturm.
Okay, wollen wir mal was zur Freifunkerei sagen?
Findet statt.
Findet statt, Freifunkerei. Ja, GPL Version 3 ist vielleicht auch nochmal ganz interessant.
Findet auch statt.
Findet auch statt. Und, ja, Hacking, du wolltest erst nochmal zu Hacking Ideologies.
Ja, genau, habe ich gerade gesehen, hier Hacking Ideologies, Part 2.
Genau.
Ja, das sind, also die dritte Person ist mir nicht bekannt, aber Marcel Maas und Tomislav Medak sind aus Kroatien, aus Zagreb und sind dort sehr aktiv mit einem, ja, einer Gruppe, die den etwas, ja, fehlleitenden Namen Multimedia-Institut hat. Was dahinter steckt, ist eigentlich eher was dem CCC sehr viel Näheres. Bekannt sind sie vor allem für ihre Location in Zagreb, den MAMA, Net Culture Club. Auch dazu gibt es bereits bei Chaosradio Express beziehungsweise bei Chaosradio Express International CRI 010, die zehnte Ausgabe, ein Interview mit Tom, wo er das ausführlich erklärt. Sehr netter Typ, ganz großartig. Kann ich euch nur empfehlen, dahin zu gehen. Das sind einfach Leute, die einfach das Herz am richtigen Fleck haben und die vor allem was tun. Also sie sind auch so der Ansprechpartner in Kroatien, wenn es um die Fragen geht, die bei uns dann immer bei uns auf den Presseverteiler auflaufen.
Ich sehe gerade, dass er sogar schon beim 23C3 hier war. Da kannte ich ihn noch nicht.
Ja, ja, da ist schon...
Also du kennst ihn ja eh schon länger, aber...
Ja, ja, das ist schon so eine... Das ist auch so ein Zeichen der zunehmenden europäischen Vernetzung. Es passiert halt eine Menge in Osteuropa und so traditionell sind natürlich da die Brücken noch nicht so breit gebaut. Aber...
Da wollen wir dranbleiben.
Da müssen wir dranbleiben und das sind auch alles hochkompatible Gruppen, gerade so in krisengeschüttelten oder zumindest ehemals krisengeschüttelten Regionen. Da kann man gar nicht nah genug dran sein.
Ja, und dann haben wir noch einen bemerkenswerten Vortrag von Amazon Ten. Der wird über Hacking in the Age of Declining Everything reden. Und zwar so ein bisschen, ja, was machen wir eigentlich, wenn es echt schief geht? Also er wird über den Klimawandel reden, über Peak Oil. Also da können wir ein paar Lebensweisheiten für Hacker erwarten. Amazon, der ist ein Brite, der war jetzt auch schon mehrfach bei uns. Der hat schon zu sehr unterschiedlichen Themen geredet und hat vor allen Dingen beim Camp eine unglaublich gute Show abgeliefert zum Powerpoint Karaoke. Er hat auch schon gesprochen über die Geschichte von Wahlen, von Wahlverfahren, war auch sehr interessant. Der ist sehr unterhaltsam, aber der hat eine coole Art, was zu erzählen. Also und Hacking in the Age of Declining Everything wird sicherlich Spaß machen.
Super, was wir auf der Liste nicht hatten, aber ich sehe es hier gerade, How to Reach Digital Sustainability ist ein Vortrag von Maike Richter.
Und Maike war auch schon öfter bei uns.
Die war schon öfter durch, aber sie hat jetzt vor allem gerade was Bemerkenswertes erreicht, nämlich sie ist so die treibende oder zumindest eine der treibenden Kräfte gewesen, hinter dem Projekt des NDR durchzusetzen, dass zumindest zwei ihrer Sendungen, also Sub und Extra 3, unter Creative Commons Lizenz veröffentlicht werden, sodass das das erste Mal komplett legal im Web dann sozusagen auch zitiert werden darf. Das heißt, die Aufzeichnungen werden unter CC-Lizenz bereitgestellt. Das ist da ein Thema. Ich denke mal, es geht hier vor allem auch um den Aktivismus. Aber sie setzt sich halt ja generell mit dieser Frage.
Das wusste ich jetzt zum Beispiel gar nicht, dass sie damit zu tun hat.
Ja, sie ist da beim NDR und ist im Wesentlichen dafür verantwortlich, dass das geschehen ist, soweit ich das beurteilen kann. Zumindest hat sie das breit angekündigt.
Dann kann man auch jedem empfehlen, hinzugehen, im Prinzip. Dann müssen wir vielleicht noch ganz allgemein über die beiden NEDAP-Vorträge reden. Rob wird natürlich aufgrund der Erfolge in den Niederlanden nochmal ausführlich berichten, das wird sehr schwierig, weil er hat nur so eine Stunde Zeit und Rob kann ja immer sehr viel erzählen.
Das stimmt. Erfolge, er hat es im Prinzip geschafft, die Wahlcomputer in Niederlanden verbieten zu lassen.
Und er kann sogar noch ein bisschen mehr erzählen. Er wird wahrscheinlich auch noch den Blick in die Zukunft wagen, weil auch da gibt es einige interessante Raten in Niederlanden zu berichten. Also wir freuen uns da eigentlich auch mit ihm. War ja schon so, dass wir ihn letztes Jahr gefeiert haben, aber jetzt ist das Ergebnis auch endgültig und sehr erfolgreich. Und wir, Frank und ich, wir werden darüber erzählen, wie es denn gerade in Deutschland aussieht. Was ist denn der neueste Stand?
Niederabwahlcomputer in Deutschland.
Wie sieht es denn da aus? Und denke, da haben wir auch eine ganze Menge zu berichten, weil der CCC hat ja in diesem Jahr Stellung genommen vom Bundesverfassungsgericht und gibt eine Klage. Also wir werden da auch wirklich mal die neuesten Fakten erzählen, die man wissen muss, wenn man auf dem Stand sein will. Und auch wie das Petitionsverfahren, wo der CCC sich echt hintergehängt hat, wie das ausgegangen ist. Ich denke, das wird nochmal interessant. Also die sind auch nacheinander, die Vorträge, aber Robben macht es auf Englisch für die Sachen in Holland. Wir machen es auf Deutsch.
Wir haben noch einen dritten Vortrag zum Thema Wahlchaos.
Wahlchaos freut uns besonders, denn das sind...
Paradoxien des deutschen Wahlsystems. Das heißt, hier wird mal unabhängig von der Wahlcomputer-Diskussion einfach mal geschaut, wie das überhaupt so mit der mathematischen Auswertung ist?
Nicht ganz unabhängig. Also Marco Schneiders von der Uni Magdeburg, und der will sich schon mal so ein bisschen auch daran orientieren, wo unsere Wahlcomputer-Problematik ist. Und eigentlich, wieviel müsste man dann manipulieren? Also er wird doch mal erklären, wie ist es denn mit den überhangenen Mandaten, was gehört denn eigentlich dazu und was ist eigentlich komisch an den deutschen Wahlen und anders als woanders. Wir über- sprechen uns da eine ganze Menge, weil das Wund-Thema hatten wir eigentlich noch nie, das ist ja eher so statistisch-mathematisch, da freuen wir uns schon sehr drauf. Da hat sich auch extra zu sagen, für uns, das Thema nochmal ein bisschen geändert und wird die Wahlcomputer...
Das ist ja schon fast Science dann.
Science, ja, kommt davon aus. Achso, meinst du jetzt, wegen der Einsortierung?
Ja, ja, aber müssen ja die Co-Menten nicht alle kacken, wie sie gegessen werden.
Okay, aber wir dürfen auf keinen Fall vergessen, wir wollten nämlich auch mal bei Cyber-Feminismus reden.
Oh, das macht Cyborg, richtig?
Da möchtest du bestimmt auch noch auf Chaosradio hinweisen.
Ja, natürlich will ich da auf Chaosradio Express hinweisen, weil Cyborg ist ja vor allem sehr bekannt in der freien Radioszene, und ist da ja sehr, also nicht nur bekannt, sondern vor allem auch extrem fleißig. Das ist Chaosradio Express 030, freie Radios, ein SIP-FM. SIP-FM ist diese Nachrichtensendung, die frei radioübergreifend ausgesendet wird und wie das so funktioniert. Darüber habe ich mit ihr gesprochen, in CRI 030.
Das ist auch sehr aktiv, so mit Beiträgen, also nicht nur dafür. Also es ist fast, man kann schon sagen, eine Schüsselfigur in den freien Radios.
Genau, und wird wahrscheinlich auch wieder vom Kongress berichtet.
Und wir haben viele freie Radios, die vom Kongress live berichten. Genau, also wir freuen uns, dass ihr euch sicher auf einen Text von generell oder auf das Werk von Donna Haraway beziehen. Nicht ganz unumstritten, aber umso spannender wollen wir also hören. Ja, was haben wir noch Interessantes? Starbuck und ich reden noch mal über Biometrie. Wie passt es? Wir haben eine Menge zu erzählen, denn die Fingerabdrücke sind ja seit dem 1. November live in den Melderemptern. Da haben wir eine Menge zu berichten, das wird auch noch mal spannend. Wir werden vor allen Dingen gucken, wie das da wirklich läuft.
Da war ja auch in den letzten Tagen schon wieder News zu dem Thema, dass das nicht so schön ist.
Das wird spannend.
Okay, wir müssen zu den Sexthemen kommen.
Jetzt schon?
Ja, dringend. Also, wir können ja nicht ohne. Das geht ja nicht.
Okay, da ist ja schon halb elf.
Ach so, du meinst wegen... Nee, das können wir auch nicht machen, oder? Wir dürfen erst nach zwölf machen.
Na so lange wollen wir den wirklich nicht noch aufnehmen. Sex 2.0 heißt das Stichwort.
Genau.
Und was läuft da so?
Ja, und da wird es gehen um Flirten und Dating. Oh, warte, ich muss mal umstellen. Sex 2.0.
Ey, Constanze, was ist denn mit Sex 2.0?
Da geht es um Dating und Flirten.
Oh, das ist ja super.
Wir werden mal...
Direkt auf der Line jetzt? Das halten wir nicht durch, oder? Hacking Heteronormativity. Was in aller Welt ist denn das? Ach so, die Heteronormalität.
Also wir werden uns mit den sozialen Auswirkungen von Online Dating...
Du weißt, wenn man rumläuft irgendwie und sagt, dann wussten sie das auf der Straße mit dem Mikrofon und sagen würden, wussten sie, dass... Wie heißt die Sabine? Christianin? Dass die heterosexuell ist, dann würden sie alle betroffen gucken. Ja.
Es würde so ein bisschen um Vergleich gehen. Also, wie unterschiedlich es irgendwie...
Der lange Schwanz der Dating-Community ist so wie die... Longtail, darauf hab ich ja nur gewartet. Die Idee und Rekonstruktion von Geschlecht und sexueller Orientierung haben ungeahnte Auswirkungen auf unser Sexualleben.
Er wählt doch einfach aus, was er so beobachtet hat in den letzten Jahren. Das wird sehr interessant.
Der Vergleich von Dating-Community ist... Toll.
Aber wir haben da noch eine interessante Sache, die wir auf keinen Fall vergessen wollen. Weil wir auch glauben, dass wir hier ein richtig kontroverse Thema haben, wo wir auch alle mal mitdiskutieren können. Und wir haben einen Referenten, und zwar Rainer Fromm von ZDF, einer der Redakteure von Frontale 21, ein sehr netter Mann. Und er hat Beiträge gemacht über Killerspiele. Und zwar ziemlich auf dem Höhepunkt der Killerspiel-Debatte dieses Jahr in Deutschland.
Mit Amstetten und Tralala.
Ganz genau. Und diese Beiträge werden wir debattieren und vor allen Dingen auch, welche Reaktionen er aus der Gamer-Szene bekommen hat.
Die Öffentlichen stehen da ja sehr im Kreuzfeuer der Kritik, insbesondere aus der Gamer-Szene, die sich da falsch dargestellt sehen. Das heißt, er wird da sozusagen auch seinen Standpunkt vertreten oder zumindest für Diskussionen?
Er bringt vor allen Dingen die Beiträge mit. Das heißt, wir sehen sie uns nochmal an. Und wir können live entscheiden, was wir davon halten. Ich glaube, das wird eine kontroverse Diskussion. Und Frank Rosengard wird die Moderation übernehmen. Das wird also ein bisschen moderiert sein, sodass man auch durchaus auf dem Publikum sich äußern soll. Da freuen wir uns drauf. Das wird sicherlich sehr spannend.
Oha, das ist ja mutig.
Er stellt sich dem, obwohl er sehr schlechte Erfahrungen gemacht hat, teilweise mit der Gamer-Szene. Ach so, mit der Gamer-Szene, ja.
Okay, die wir ja so nicht sind. Spielfreude, Eierkuchen heißt das hier.
Ja, Spielfreude, Eierkuchen. Also da sollte jeder hingehen, der selber spielt und vielleicht eine Meinung hat und sich ein bisschen einbringen will. Der ist da genau richtig. Ja gut, über den Tour-Tour können wir schon gesprochen. Walcaos. Ja, wir haben noch so ein Highlight, das man wohl auf keinen Fall verpassen sollte. Und zwar unter dem Titel Was ist eigentlich Terrorismus? Wenn wir im Großen Saal einen Vortrag hören von einer Betroffenen. Und zwar betroffen in dem Sinne, dass ein Angehöriger von ihr verdächtigt wird, Terrorist zu sein. Und sie ist in die Mühlen des Überwachungsstaates und Präventionsstaates geraten. Und das wird sie erzählen.
Also sozusagen das, was wir immer so als schwarze Vision an die Wände werfen, wie mit gerunzelter Stirn über unsere Themen referieren, dass es hier mal konkret auch passiert.
Wir werden einfach einen Opfer kennenlernen. Wir hatten ja schon eine Chaosradio-Sendung bei Fritzen, wo wir einen Betroffenen hatten. Sie ist aber sehr direkt betroffen. Sie ist eine Enge, also die Ehefrau von einem Betroffenen. Und da sind wir eigentlich sehr gespannt auf das Feedback. Denn da werden ja viele Fragen kommen. Der Fall ist bekannt hier in Berlin, aber auch überregional bekannt. Geht um Soziologen und seine angebliche Mitgliedschaft in einer terroristischen Vereinigung, also dessen er verdächtigt wird.
Und dann können wir ja mal gucken, ob das nun wirklich die Art von Terrorismus ist, die wir mit Vorratsdatenspeicherung bekämpfen möchten.
Und der Untertitel ist, wer terrorisiert hier eigentlich wen. Denn sie wird mal ein bisschen berichten, wie das eigentlich ist, wenn man neun Monate lang das komplette Privatleben in den Akten wiederfindet. Okay, da freuen wir uns sehr, dass sie zugesagt hat und kommt und sich da auch irgendwie in unserer Community, die sich normalerweise eher mit der technischen Seite der Überwachung befasst, sprechen kann.
Da freuen wir uns.
Okay, und vielleicht zu allerletzter sollten wir dringend drüber reden. What can we do to counter the spies? Wir haben also eine Referentin aus UK.
Die darüber berichtet, was man gegen Spione tun kann. Und sie war selber eine?
Richtig, sie und ihr Mann waren selber Spione. Und sie wird auch darüber berichten, was passiert, wenn man es dann, also die Whistleblower wird im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes. Genau, also das ist ganz interessant, weil sie hat halt quasi aus moralischen Gründen.
Aus generellen Erwägungen.
Genau.
Bist du dir sicher, dass das mit den, ah ne, Entschuldigung, ich hab falsch geguckt. Saal 1.
Weil ich hab grad Saal 3 gelesen, aber es ist der dritte Tag. Primetime.
Genau, also da sind wir sehr gespannt.
Na gut, 11.30 Uhr ist nicht gerade Primetime, aber ich hoffe, da sind schon wieder alle wach.
Auf Wunsch der Referentin. Also wir sind da sehr gespannt.
Ja, auch Referentenwünsche werden berücksichtigt.
Aber selbstverständlich. Wir haben das oft, dass man sagt, okay, kann ich am letzten Tag oder am ersten Mal, dann muss ich noch bei Mama die Ente essen. Natürlich, also wir sind ja nicht, also immer, wir sind total nett und kooperativ.
Ja, und da haben wir eine Software, der das Feature enthalten ist, dass man das aufbereichern kann.
Wobei, andererseits, das ändert sich manchmal auch. Nicht alle Referenten klingen da zum Beispiel, an welchen Tagen sie wirklich available sind. Da gibt es so ein Feld. Aber wir kriegen es immerhin. Ein bisschen schieben, dafür haben wir Henrik. Henrik ist der Fahrplan-Schieber. Weil diese Probleme können wir noch nicht technisch ausdrücken.
Fahrplan-Schieber Henrik. Mit dem hab ich auch schon mal ein Chaosradio Express.
Worüber?
Über die FIFA WM-Tickets, wo er sich anschaut. Und macht er nicht darüber auch noch einen Vortrag?
Das wissen wir nicht genau. Henrik wird aber einen Vortrag halten. Das wird noch mal sehr spannend.
Was wir das verraten.
Wir haben ja hier noch ein paar freie Plätze.
Wir müssen kurz unsere Hörer hypnotisieren, damit sie das jetzt nicht gehört haben.
Wir müssen zur nächsten Kategorie kommen. Dann sitzen wir hier echt noch am 27.
Ja, dann machen wir das doch einfach. Was haben wir denn noch?
Ah, Kultur heißt das auf Neudeutsch.
Das geht um Kultur. Und zwar sind das eigentlich die Sachen, die jetzt nicht um Technik und wo es nicht ganz so bedrohlich wird, sondern wo wir einfach auch Spaß haben.
Ja Kultur, was ist Kultur, Tim? Da können wir jetzt ja auch schon drüber reden. Das können wir nicht definieren.
Na, das kann auf jeden Fall hier gleich der erste Referent, den wir erwähnen.
Alle beide.
Das sind zwei?
Also nein, zwei Talks von ihm.
Das meine ich doch, genau.
Zwei Happen-Links.
Wer könnte besser Kultur erklären als Johannes Grenzfurtner von Monochrome? Die Jungs sind wirklich unglaublich. Was ich bei denen immer noch nicht verstehe ist, wie schaffen die das? Jede Woche, da hast du mal den Blog verfolgt, die kündigen jede Woche irgendwas an, was sie gerade getan haben. Und es sind immer so monströse Dinge wie, ja, wir haben gerade eine Veranstaltung in San Francisco gemacht, ja, wir haben ein neues Theaterstück rausgebracht und nächste Woche haben wir noch ein Hörspiel hier. Ja, es sind ein paar, aber es ist trotzdem unglaublich, wie man das alles koordiniert bekommt.
Es ist auf jeden Fall Drogen und Sex.
Es ist immer super lustig. Ich war jetzt gerade in Wien nach dieser Security-Konferenz, war halt oder mehr oder weniger zeitgleich, lief halt noch ihre Robo-Exeutica, also der Festival for Cocktail Robotics, einfach Hammer. Also großartige Installationen mit irgendwie...
Ich hab ein paar Bilder gesehen, die total toll waren.
Ich glaub, ich muss mir ihn mal schnappen, da muss ich auch mal ein bisschen ziehen.
Tu mal den Link ins Chaosradio Express.
Zu was?
Zu Robo-Exotica.
Robo-Exotica, ja, natürlich.
Ich glaub, das wäre schön. Überhaupt mal vielleicht zum Monochrom, was man da hinklickt.
Monochrom war ja auch auf dem letzten Congress schon der totale Hit, weil sie da mit der Gitarre aufgetaucht sind und das großartige It's Fun to Hack the RFID aufgebracht haben, gibt's auch bei ChaosTV. So eine Sendung liebe ich, ich kann die ganze Zeit Eigenwerbung machen.
Na ja, ist ja auch eine Congress-Sendung, honey.
Stimmt, aber auch für Express. Und ChaosTV, also Hack the RFID, ich notiere das sofort. Und jetzt kommt wieder Sex.
Vielleicht wollen wir mal generell sagen, dass eben Monochrom...
Achso, was sind denn die beiden, was ist die andere Veranstaltung eigentlich?
I can't count every star in the heavens above, but I have no heart, I can't fall in love. Ein knapper Titel.
Ja, sehr kurz gehalten.
Also das heißt, Monochrom wird eigentlich die Hälfte unseres Abendprogramms bestreiten.
Computers as a thankful subject in Pop-Music. Bourgeoisie Kultur. So, so. Okay, 0.30 Uhr geht's los. Na, wenn das mal nicht das optimale Nachtprogramm ist.
Aber wir haben auch noch ein Nachtprogramm, was richtig spät in der Nacht ist, der Rule 34 Contest.
Da-da-da-da-da.
If you can think of it, there's porn of it on the Internet. Das heißt, das kommt aus der XK-CD, diesem großartigen Webcomic. Und diese Rule besagt, wenn man in der Lage ist, sich irgendwas auszudenken, dann gibt's auch Porn davon. Und das stimmt halt. Das ist so eine Self-fulfilling Prophecy, würde ich sagen. Und worum geht's in dem Vortrag?
Es ist kein Vortrag, es ist ein Contest nachts. Und zwar haben wir die Spezialisten des CCC zusammengeholt.
Die Sexspezialisten?
Ja, Edgar, Tina, Andreas und Nibbler.
Ach, Nibbler auch?
Ja, natürlich, ein großer Spezialist dafür. Und wir werden gucken, wie sie Zeit beschränkt. Diese Regel umsetzen können, praktisch. Das wird sehr lustig.
Super, also Nibbler, der hier auch sonst über Voice-over-IP berichtet, weiß auch zu Sex eine Menge Dinge zu berichten. Wobei der hohe Priester... Der hohe Priester ist Andreas.
Muss man wohl sagen. Aber Tina hat ja letztes Jahr über Porn geredet, beim Kongress.
Und den Saal 2 zum Saal 1 gemacht.
Richtig. Und ja, also Erdgeist muss man auch sagen, na ja, schon Guru der Bewegung.
Also die Sex-Götter des CCC laden euch ein nachts um 0 Uhr in Saal 1 abends. Dinge auszudenken, für denen es dann Porn gibt. Da bin ich ja mal gespannt.
Das wird sehr lustig. Okay, wollen wir noch zur letzten Kategorie kommen? Community auch nicht unwichtig, denn Gruppen kuscheln, ich hatte dir erwähnt, ist eine wichtige Sache auf dem Kongress. Wir brauchen Community-Projekte.
Ja, das stimmt.
Genau, vielleicht würdest du was sagen zu Billinger Hacker Space?
Billinger Hacker Space, ja, das ist gut. Und zwar der vorletzte Chaosradio Express 55 war ja aus Wien, wie auch schon erwähnt, zum Thema MetaLab und das ist ja eins der besten Beispiele derzeit für neue Hacker Spaces, die entstehen. Und der Jens Ohlig, der hier den Vortrag macht, zusammen mit Pellone, mit Lars Weiler, der hat sich mal so im Nachgang der Errichtung dieser ganzen Hacker Spaces in Deutschland, also LaboA, C4 und so weiter, diese ganzen Clubs und Orte, die in den letzten Jahren hier so entstanden sind, hat er sich Design Patterns ausgedacht. Es steht hier auch Hacker Space Design Pattern Katalog. Das heißt, er hat tatsächlich mal versucht, ganz nerdisch, das Aufbauen von solchen Locations und von solchen kulturellen Orten ganz konkret in Regeln zusammenzufassen, was man halt machen kann, was denn ich. Das sind sehr gute Empfehlungen, wie Kommunikation zu funktionieren hat und so weiter, wie man das mit dem Aufräumen macht und so weiter. Also wirklich ganz konkrete Sachen. Ich hab mir das auch mal angeschaut, hatte auch noch so ein paar ergänzende Hinweise. Mal schauen, was jetzt dabei rausgekommen ist. Das Ding ist schon ein bisschen länger in Arbeit. Von daher bin ich sehr zuversichtlich, dass das ein sehr interessanter Vortrag wird. Blinger Hacker Space. Das ist definitiv Community.
Ja, kann man sagen.
Chaos Jahresrückblick hatten wir schon erwähnt.
Ja, da ist es ja, wie gesagt, ein bisschen länger, weil wir einfach viel zu erzählen haben.
Hacker Jopper, die hatten wir auch schon erwähnt.
Genau, naja, da kann man vielleicht, also eigentlich, wenn es die meisten kennen. Das wird sicherlich nochmal spaßig.
Es ist immer wieder lustig.
Also das ist dieses umgekehrte Frage-Antwort-Schema. Und ja, sie denken sich auch, die sind ja wieder neue Kategorien aus, die wir vielleicht noch nicht kennen.
Letztes Jahr war irgendwie was Tolles dabei, aber ich hab wieder vergessen, was es war.
Strings, Faith, Doesn't Know?
Nee, es war was anderes. Irgendwas hat mir sehr gut gefallen.
Ich hatte parallel den PowerPoint-Koror, okay, ich hab es dir verpasst.
Stimmt, das war ein Fehler, das parallel zu machen war.
Wir hatten nicht mehr Slots.
Ja, wir haben nicht Slots. Vielleicht müssen wir den Kongress auf zehn Tage erweitern. Was meinst du?
Das kannst du aber echt alleine machen.
Dann kann danach der gesamte CCC und alle Leute, die dahin gekommen sind, danach noch mal ihren Jahresurlaub verbraten. Also zur Hälfte auf dem Kongress und zur anderen Hälfte auf Mallorca. Dann hat man sich von dem ganzen Trubel wieder erholt.
Zumindest braucht man mindestens ein, zwei Tage Erholung. Tja, damit haben wir eigentlich, muss man schon sagen.
Okay, es gibt natürlich noch sehr viel mehr Community, aber das sind dann eben auch viele Veranstaltungen, die dann so Treffen sind von Leuten und so weiter, die jetzt nicht so sehr hier reinpassen, wo wir ja im Wesentlichen Vorträge vorstellen.
Wir haben natürlich auch wieder ein R-Verkreis Treffen. Der eigentlich auch zur Community gehört im Workshop-Raum. Wir haben überhaupt viele Workshops. Wir haben auch wieder die Lightning-Talks, also diese Kurz-Talks, diese 3-5 Minuten.
Jeden Tag wieder einen oder wie?
Oh, das weiß ich noch gar nicht. Das wird wieder im Wiki selbst organisiert passieren, wo sie sich da eintragen können. Also ich denke, auch da haben wir noch mal eine Menge. So ein bisschen mit Anfassen und so. Da freuen wir uns eigentlich auch drauf.
Ringelpiz?
Dann meinst du mehr Anfassen von Sachen.
Also noch muss ich gerade kritisieren, ist noch kein Lightning Talk eingetragen.
Nee, das sind nur noch drei Wochen.
Naja, also wir hatten schon mal das Programm schneller fertig, aber das Ganze ist Version 0.05. Also das ist ja sehr zurückhaltend.
Also wir haben noch einige Lücken, sieht man ja auch. Also klar. Und gerade so, wenn jetzt an...
Vielleicht sollen wir das mit Lightning Talks... Also wer der Meinung ist, dass er etwas Spritziges beizutragen hat, was man in vier Minuten zusammenfassen kann, der kann sich im Wiki eintragen zum Lightning Talk und sagen ja prima, alles klar, ich werde hier einen Vortrag halten. Deswegen solltet ihr jetzt zuschlagen und da möglicherweise noch freie Slots auch für euch belegen. Und wenn ihr euch da eintragen müsst, ihr auf jeden Fall auch kommen. Ich glaube, ihr müsst ja sogar noch einen Kontakt irgendwie hinterlassen, keine Ahnung, zumindest einen Account im Wiki machen, wäre vielleicht ganz brauchbar, damit die Leute auch ansprechbar sind, weil wir müssen halt irgendwie das auch koordinieren können.
Wer sich jetzt durch den Pfappen klickt und irgendwie feststellt, da sind ja noch freie Slots und sogar welche im Saal 1, der weiß, dass es noch eine Überraschung gibt.
Mindestens eine Überraschung gibt.
Mehr als eine.
Mehr als eine Überraschung gibt, denn wir lieben Überraschungen.
Genau. Wir möchten ja schließlich auch, ja genau, wir möchten den Leuten überraschen.
Auf dem 24. Chaos Communication Congress gibt es noch Features, die man so erwähnen sollte, die dieses Jahr so stattfinden. Also im Prinzip ist es so ein bisschen Business as usual. Der untere Bereich wird sich ändern, dadurch dass wir Workshop-Raum, also es werden zwei Workshop-Raume sein, wenn ich es richtig verstanden habe. Und eine größere Lounge.
Genau, wir wollen auch ein bisschen unten wieder ein bisschen mehr chilligen Atmosphäre und nicht so dieses Campen an Tischen.
Das heißt, oben im Art und Beauty-Bereich wird noch ein bisschen mehr Action sein und Essen und unten ist dann sozusagen entspanntes Beisammensein.
Und wir haben eine Kita.
Was, es gibt eine Kita?
Es wird eine Kita geben.
Krass, wo denn? Ich will das wissen.
Du wirst sie ja sehen. Du wirst sie sogar brauchen.
Wie alt dürfen denn die Kinder da sein?
Ich finde das auch sehr schön, was hat sich auch beim Camp bewährt. Wir haben noch was Neues.
Es gibt auch einen Wickelraum.
Wir lernen, dass auch die Hacker mittlerweile älter werden und einfach Familien gründen und sich vermehren und die jungen Hacker züchten.
Das ist auch ein super Projekt, kann ich dir empfehlen.
Wir haben jetzt ja auch erstmal wieder einen Pressroom, also einen Raum für die Presse. Wir sind ein größeres Presse-Team und wir haben auch mehr Anmeldungen, aber es gibt keine Pressekonferenz mehr, sondern eine individualisierte Betreuung.
Das heißt, wenn jemand von der Presse sich tatsächlich jetzt hier durch, wie lange sind wir jetzt eigentlich schon dabei, eineinhalb Stunden Podcast durchquält hat, dann schreibt er einfach eine Mail.
Ja, da gibt es ein bisschen klickt ins Blog, da gibt es die Adresse, da ist so ein kleiner Blog-Eintrag für die Presse-Accreditation. Also bis wann die läuft, also wir sind da ziemlich offen für Presse mittlerweile, das hat sich in den Jahren auch ein bisschen gewandelt. Also wir freuen uns eigentlich über seriöse Presse, aber wir möchten schon, dass sie sich vorab akkreditiert, dazu schreibt man einfach nur eine E-Mail. Am besten ist, man klickt ins Blog, da ist so ein Eintrag dazu.
Genau, das ist wichtig, einfach so aufkreuzen und sagen Hallo, ich bin Presse am Eingang.
Das läuft nicht. Aber dafür haben wir auch so eine Regel, dass wir uns sagen, okay, das Gesetz behandelt Blogger wie Presse. Und entsprechend behandeln wir auch Blogger wie Presse. Das heißt Blogger, die regelmäßig live berichten. Also das heißt nicht nur so ein Privatblogger.
Die sozusagen auch wirklich eine Publikation vorzuweisen haben. Es muss nicht immer so groß sein wie Netzpolitik, aber was seriös ist, nehmen wir natürlich an.
Die wollen wir sehr gerne haben. Und wir haben auch eine Menge alternative Projekte, muss man schon sagen, die zu uns kommen von sonst wo auf der Welt und da irgendwie Radio oder Blogs machen oder so. Die wollen wir, freuen wir uns.
Genau, oder auch Podcaster.
Oder auch Podcaster. Ich hatte ehrlich gesagt, die sind ja noch keinen, der es hier angemeldet hat, aber kommt bestimmt noch.
Ja, ich hoffe das sehr. Also ich weiß auf jeden Fall von ein paar Technik-Podcastern so aus der deutschen Landschaft, die auch da sind. Ich weiß nicht, ob sie wirklich vorhaben, direkt dort irgendwas zu produzieren, aber im Nachgang wird auf jeden Fall da auch immer wieder was gemacht. Aber ich finde das gerade gut, wenn viel vor Ort auch noch gemacht wird. Ich will auch selber zusehen, Chaosradio Express das ein oder andere zu produzieren, mache aber wie immer.
Es wird wahrscheinlich kommen und live sein.
Das ist schön, da freuen wir uns drüber. Und ja, mit Chaosradio Express weiß ich nicht, das hängt immer noch ein bisschen davon ab, weil es ist immer so viel los auf diesem Kongleis. Diese Veranstaltung ist wie die Wohnungstür im Herbst öffnen und es ist Sturm.
Dann kommt da Laub rein.
Dann kommt rein, dann kommt das Laub und der Wind und dann treibt man schon irgendwie so, oh, was ist denn hier los?
Wir merken schon, langsam hat Tim die Seltsamenvergleiche. Niemand braucht sich davon irritieren lassen.
Aber stimmt doch.
Ja, mit dem Laub, na ja.
Ich finde Laub ist super. Laub ist divers. Laub hat viele Farben. Das ist pures Chaos.
Es muss wahrscheinlich so sein, dass bei Tims Tür ein besonderer Windfang ist, sodass ich immer...
Ich liebe den Herbst. Ich mochte den Herbst schon immer. Es ist Zeit der Melancholie. Das ist alles, was sehr positiv ist.
Wir sollten gleich noch erwähnen, dass Tim Pritlove uns durch das Programm führen wird mit dem Opening- und Closing-Event. Und quasi die Eröffnung und den Schluss machen wird. Und erklären wird, warum wir in diesem Jahr volldarm vorausgehen. Haben wir noch etwas Wichtiges vergessen?
Bestimmt.
Ja, bestimmt.
Haben wir. Aber so ist das. Niemals kann ein Podcast alles erklären. Wenngleich auch eine Menge.
Wir müssen davon sagen, wer nicht hingeht, ist echt selber schuld.
Genau, wer nicht hingeht, ist selber schuld zum 24. Chaos Communication Congress. 27. bis 30. Dezember. Und wir möchten, dass ihr alle kommt. Das war's. Tiramisu ist sowieso schon alle. Dann können wir ja hier auch enden. Wir bedanken uns für das aufmerksame Zuhören und hoffen, euch wieder unterhalten zu haben. Bei Chaosradio Express, der Ausgabe Nummer 58. Kommentare sind gern gesehen. Blog chaosradio ccc.de oder ihr schreibt eine E-Mail an chaosradio.ccc.de Feedback ist der Treibstoff dieses Podcasts. Umso mehr Feedback, umso mehr Podcasts. Also wenn ihr viel hören wollt, dann müsst ihr auch viel schreiben. In diesem Sinne sagen wir jetzt ganz artig Tschüss.
Tschüss.
Bis bald bei Chaosradio Express.